Sure.
Are we live?
Oh my goodness.
Rich Roll.
Ladies and gentlemen.
How are you buddy?
Good to see Ya.
What's cracking?
Happy to be here,
man.
I'm drinking green juice interview.
I hope that's in my honor.
Sort of.
I drink it every day,
but appreciate that helps.
Where'd you pick that up?
Juicy lady.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You know what that is?
I do.
I go there all the time.
I love that place.
I wish I changed the name of it,
but a juicy ladies.
I don't know why it's.
I think a lady owns it.
Yeah.
Now she's cool.
Actually.
I like it,
but yeah,
the food there is pretty good.
It's a little sexual.
Yeah.
The name or is it an assault of your
masculinity?
No,
no.
I'm cool with that,
but some weaker men might have an issue.
You have to be selfish.
You have to be strong enough to go in
there and order Vegan food.
They do,
but they make a good green juice.
Yeah.
They make a lot of good stuff there.
It's a good spot where there's more and
more of those places that are opening
up.
If Mcdonald's is going to offer a Kale
shake,
no way.
That's changing though.
Well,
something's working well.
We're getting nutrients in their body.
It's crazy.
Starbucks.
Starbucks has what?
Get the fuck out.
I didn't know that.
Yeah,
get the fuck Outta here.
Evo Green things.
It makes it up with a yogurt and fresh
Kale if you want it to,
but why would they put yogurt in it?
Because it makes it a smoother start.
Starbucks makes us.
Well,
you know the market.
The market will dictate it if people
want.
It started like when you talk about
conspiracy theories with evil
corporations,
it's like they're responding to what
people want.
You know?
That is true.
People want it.
They're going to start making it.
That's the whole conspiracy with really
shitty television shows to like people
like men.
They're trying to make us dumb.
Nope.
Already dumb like you have to do is look
at the ratings and see what people are
actually watching it and they're
responding to that.
Well,
people are tired.
They get home from work,
they're exhausted.
They don't want to watch cosmos or some
of them do.
I do,
but some people just want to,
they just want to zone out and watch
honey booboo or I don't think that's
right anymore.
There's always a new one.
But yeah,
we uh,
we got rid of our TVS.
Yeah,
like are you like a year ago?
But believe me,
I did not want to do.
It was not my idea.
I was uh,
I was quite vociferous in opposing that
idea.
That was my wife's idea.
But actually it's just like anything
else you adjust to it.
I mean I still watch Netflix and I watch
the shows I like to watch and now I
don't,
I don't miss it.
And I have total,
like when I've been traveling a lot and
you know,
when you're in hotel rooms,
he turned the TV on and I have a zero
tolerance policy for commercials now.
Like I'm like really,
you know,
and I just turned the TV off and go back
online.
Yeah,
commercials are fucking brutal.
Whoever invented the idea of stopping a
show every 15 minutes for three minutes
or whatever the hell it is for
commercials.
That's awful.
Well,
it's crazy how you acclimate to that
because as a kid,
you know,
think about how many hours of your life,
we're just basically watching
commercials.
Well,
you know what happened though,
dvrs,
dvrs made commercials really stupid.
That's still.
I mean we're about the same age,
right?
So that's still a recent development in
our life.
You know,
most of our formative years was terrible
television commercials.
Yeah.
I got my first vo in the early two
thousands.
It was like a standalone unit that
hooked up to direct TV.
I think it was like,
I want to say like 2003 or something
like that.
And I was like,
this is amazing.
You can pause the TV now.
You can pause it and go take a leak.
You could record things.
You could find search things and have
them on a schedule.
Because I fucking.
I had probably 10 vcrs in my life and
never figured out how to record one of
those pitches.
This flashing 12:00,
I'd never scheduled one of them.
I never had one of them scheduled,
unlike anybody figured that out.
Some people must have.
It's cool how it's changing,
I mean,
you know,
to see how,
how you know,
what's going on with Netflix and Amazon
and all that kind of stuff.
And,
and most recently what Tim Ferriss has
done with his show,
have you followed that at all?
Which was so,
so tim had a show called the Tim Ferriss
experiment in an era on.
I can't remember what.
Yeah,
it was,
uh,
it was like a,
another channel that was part of the CNN
headline news or it wasn't headline news
where it was something like that.
It went under.
Right.
And so his show was,
I don't know how many episodes had
aired,
but certainly not the entire 13,
you know,
of the season.
And then it was just,
you know,
how it is an entertainment like you're
just done,
right.
They own the show.
And even though they were all taped and
locked in and completed,
nobody had seen them and somehow he was
able to get,
get his show back and he,
he,
I dunno,
you know,
through loitering or what have you.
And uh,
bought the rights back,
got his show and cut a deal with itunes
and it's premiered on itunes this past
week and I think it's like the top
ranked TV show on itunes
now you can watch the TV show rankings
though,
or just like their podcast rankings,
you know.
Well,
who knows how the,
it knows that algorithm works well.
It does.
It's definitely not based on the number
of downloads.
No,
it's definitely not.
It's based on new,
like it,
it knew it takes precedent,
new subscribers and,
and also uh,
comments.
So like Chelsea Peretti had the number
one podcast in the country and she
hadn't even released an episode yet.
Right.
So zero had been downloaded and they
also put subscribed.
They overinflate new shows.
Someone,
somebody premiers a show with one or two
episodes that it's like super high up
for awhile before it settles into where
it should be.
I think that's good because it doesn't
keep anybody from downloading other
shows that are already popular.
And it does give new shows like a
window.
But like,
you'll see people,
I'm number one,
like you'll see like these bright like
come on man.
Like do you know what that means?
What is it?
What are your numbers?
How many downloads?
EA?
Definitely not number one there.
It's weird.
The rankings is weird.
It was all over the,
like my show
this week.
Uh,
it's got a banner on the top carousel of
Itunes,
on the itunes homepage for podcasts.
So my numbers went way up this week and
overall rankings,
but I know that's not real.
You know,
it'll settle back down and then we will.
But it won't,
you know,
it will,
but it'll build,
you know,
I remember when we first started doing
this podcast,
I don't know what our downloads were.
There were,
there were nothing though.
It was like,
you know,
a few thousand here or there.
And then one day it was like,
oh,
we're getting a million downloads a
month.
What?
A million.
And now it's somewhere around 14
million.
Is it really?
Yeah.
What's your,
what's your average download per show?
You can you talk about that ends?
It depends on the show,
but there's all the different things.
There's Itunes,
then there's the raw mp3 that you can
download there,
stitcher,
which is really hard to track.
Yeah.
You don't know what's going on.
Stitcher only takes one.
They'll give you numbers,
but you know,
chase it down to what they do is
stitcher is an application for cell
phones that allows,
they take a podcast and they below are
the bit rate and make it a much smaller
file and then they,
so they only download one episode,
but then it gets distributed through
their system,
you know,
I don't know how many times.
So then there's that.
Then there's Ustream,
which is a few thousand usually.
Um,
and then there's youtube,
which is tens if not hundreds of
thousands,
usually hundreds of thousands.
And then,
um,
it's never tens of thousands.
Um,
and then,
um,
vimeo.
So altogether it's usually around a
billion an episode depending on the
episode.
Crazy.
Yeah.
It could be more crazy numbers,
you know,
powerful jewelry.
Well,
it's just a number thing.
Just you keep doing it.
Have interesting people like rich roll.
It isn't,
gentlemen,
have interesting people on have funny
conversations,
fun conversations,
and just keep doing it and it built.
I just listened to your episode with Sam
Harris from the other day and it's just
he.
That guy is captivating.
Yeah.
He's an interesting dude.
He's a very intelligent,
very cool guy.
I want to get him together with Abby
Martin though.
I.
She's got down the same room.
I'm sure your phone rang from her after
that show.
I got a few text messages.
We went back and forth.
She's my friend.
I'm very good friends with her and I'm
good friends with Sam too.
I like both of them.
Well,
Sam's got a next level brain.
Yeah.
He's very smart.
Whether you agree with him or not,
he has an incredible acuity to present
an argument and support it and
communicate it in a very clear and calm
way.
He's also very honest,
you know,
like,
uh,
if he's communicating and argument he is
not doing it to be deceptive.
These are his actual feelings and
thoughts and agree with them or not
agreeing with them.
This is his point of view and uh,
as,
as hard as,
you know,
I mean,
I respect both of them very much.
I,
I'm in the middle between both as well.
I'm not necessarily 100 percent her
side.
I'm not necessarily hundred percent his
Um,
it's,
uh,
you know,
you're talking about death and war and
uh,
anytime you can find any way to minimize
or trivialize that,
it's easily open for argument,
open for criticism.
So that's where I see,
I see her point of view,
but I also see his point of view.
It's a lot of fucking crazy people in
the world.
What a awful,
terrible people.
There's a lot of really dangerous
ideologies that are being passed around
and have been passed around for a long
time.
And the people that are embedded in
these ideologies are married to them.
They're very,
very committed to it.
And you know,
I see his point of view.
He knows what he's talking about and to
shade.
So it's,
it's crazy,
you know.
Well,
a couple things.
I mean,
first of all,
I'm always impressed with how you kind
of navigate the treacherous waters of
having guests on that you may disagree
with,
which may beat me today,
I don't know,
but you know,
sort of yell,
you'll have people with different point
of view,
sometimes extreme,
sometimes not,
uh,
and,
and the way that you kind of have to
gracefully like as a podcast.
So it's myself,
that's always a challenge,
you know,
like how do you,
um,
have a respectful,
engaging conversation,
um,
but also make sure that you're asking
the right questions so that you're not
just people pleasing.
Well,
I don't think there's anything wrong
with disagreeing with someone,
you know,
and I don't think there's anything wrong
with having a pleasant conversation with
someone whose views you don't share.
I think two people can be diametrically
opposed on certain issues,
but still be nice to each other.
I don't think there's anything wrong
with that.
And I think when I talked to someone who
doesn't share my opinions or has
differing opinions,
I tried to relax whatever part of me
wants to argue with that and just try to
figure out what is it,
where they come in from,
you know,
where's,
what's their point of view based on is
it logical,
is it emotional,
is it objective,
is it non,
where,
where were they at,
you know?
And also I like to play,
like sometimes people say you have a,
you asked this,
that.
And sometimes I'll ask people things
that I don't even,
I don't even believe what I'm saying,
what I'm,
what I'm trying to do is either play
devil's advocate or argue the
counterpoint just to try to figure out
where they're at and try to cover all
the bases.
Because especially when it comes to a
controversial issue,
you know,
you want,
you want to explore not just where a
person's at,
like what,
what they're trying to say,
but how did they come to that
conclusion?
Right.
And in the case of Sam,
I mean,
he's traveled extensively.
He has firsthand experience with all
these kinds of people.
Um,
so he has a basis from where,
you know,
for where he's coming from.
A,
I was actually a funny story about him.
I've never met him,
I don't know him,
but we were classmates.
We were in the same freshman class in
college at Stanford and uh,
and I don't,
like I said I don't know him,
but we have mutual friends in common so
a couple of guys that I'm close with
that he's still close with and I was
talking to one of them recently and you
just said we were talking about Sam
because he's blown up and he's
everywhere and he's so insight guy
straighten out.
And uh,
he was telling me that in some freshmen,
I don't know if it was a freshman
English class or something like that,
that,
that he,
that Sam just distinguished himself
immediately,
like by challenging the professor and
just everybody knew that he was on a
nother level intellectually at a,
at a young age.
Well,
it's got to be very difficult if you're
in college and you're taking classes
from a person that you think is a dumb
ass,
which does happen.
Right,
right.
I mean,
I had it happen in college.
I can clearly remember.
I forgot what class it was in,
but I can clearly remember going,
oh,
all right,
well now I have to just think only of
the information,
the,
the actual numbers and the data that's
being presented in this class and ignore
this person's opinion because there are
a fucking idiot.
It was,
I believe it was either a philosophy
class or a psychology class.
I don't remember the exact circumstance,
but I remember thinking like,
Oh,
this is a real issue.
And then as I got older and I started
paying attention to some of the things
that get taught in school and some of
the like very rigid ideologies.
It's some people especially like really
super lefties like to impose on students
and some of the ideas they tried to
impose on students are very.
It's a very subjective ideas.
You know,
very,
very much personal opinions.
They get stuffed into kids' heads and
then it becomes an issue of whether or
not you know whether or not you want
that in your head.
Whether or not.
I mean,
you're going to get an a in this class
if you disagree with this guy,
but still present good arguments or
you're going to have to go along with
the way this person is trying to portray
the world in order to be graded
accordingly.
I don't think critical thought is really
taught to the extent that it should be
in young people.
You know,
we're on this.
Our education system is about,
you know,
getting through as much information as
possible and standardized testing and
you know,
getting good grades and all that kind of
thing and you know,
the idea that you should be questioning
the ideas that are presented to you is
really not something that is part of
that world to the extent that I think it
should be.
I agree.
And I also think that there's very
little being taught,
especially at a high school level of how
to think and not just like,
this is mathematics,
this is the way you calculate things.
This is,
these are the facts of history that
we're aware of instead of how do you
deal with problems,
how do you address interpersonal
relationships?
How do you,
how do you look at yourself objectives?
Do you ever step back and try to look at
yourself the way maybe someone else
would and judge yourself and your own
actions instead of protecting yourself
with your ego and all those things that
people do like almost naturally to
protect themselves,
really wind up being traps.
It really wind up fucking you up and you
have to kind of clean up that mess as
you get older.
Well,
I mean,
I guess that's supposed to be on the
parents.
You know what I mean?
They don't do it either like life
skills.
What about just,
you know,
learning how to navigate this crazy
world that we're living in,
you know,
about learning how to eat.
For me,
the most important thing,
you know,
as a parents,
it's like I want my kids to be excited
about life and to be excited about
something,
to figure out a way to be passionate
about something because if they have
that motor,
that drive,
that is half the game right there.
And then also to have that ability to
critically,
you know,
to want to learn the desire to learn as
much more important than whatever you're
learning.
Yeah.
So how do you make your kid enthusiastic
about that?
Especially when they're getting beaten
down,
you've got to find whatever it is that
they're drawn to.
Right?
Yeah.
So you expose them to a lot of things
and then when they find something that
they kind of gravitate towards your job
is to support that.
At least that's how I see it.
Yeah.
And then give them the opportunity to
switch gears to.
I remember when I was a kid I would be
into a lot of different things and my
parents would always be like super
resistant.
If I got into something else,
they'd be like,
well what about the other thing that you
do?
When I'm like,
well I want to do this now.
Stop fucking with me.
What were you into?
Well,
initially I was really into art.
You're crazy drawer.
That's what I used to do.
Yeah,
all the all day long.
When I was really young,
I was A.
I wanted to be a comic book illustrator,
so I used to draw a lot and then um,
when I was in my teenage years I
discovered martial arts and that's all I
wanted to do.
And my parents were like,
why do you want to do that?
Like,
why are you doing that when you used to
do this?
I'm like,
because that's what I liked.
Now can,
I just liked it.
And they said that presupposes that you
have to make a choice between two
things.
Like why do you have to define yourself
by one of those?
Well,
why couldn't you be my dad?
What happened?
Where were you when my mom was hot?
Yeah,
I think there's,
um,
you know,
it's,
a lot of it is people,
you know,
they're raising their kids,
they just want the best for their kids.
They just maybe don't have the best
ideas,
you know,
they don't necessarily know.
And it's also like,
I mean,
I was born in 1967,
so my parents were basically cave
people.
I mean,
let's be realistic,
like people that were,
if you're,
if you're born in [inaudible] 67,
that means your parents were.
My parents were born in [inaudible] 47,
right?
My mom was like 20 when she had me.
So w 1947.
That's fucking world war two.
Dude,
that means that her parents were born
during World War One.
My,
her parents came over on the boat from
Italy.
It's,
they're savages.
They're basically,
they might as well be Magellan,
right?
Well there too.
I mean,
I was born in [inaudible] 66,
so same,
same basic idea.
My parents,
you know,
they're,
they're too old to have been part of
kind of sixties subculture.
Um,
so they kind of missed that part but too
young to kind of be seventies vibe also.
So there's sort of a weird like light
dusting of mad men era,
you know,
and they're great people.
I love my parents,
you know,
their,
their fans and they did the best job
that they could raising me and work
clothes and all that kind of stuff.
But,
but they live,
you know,
they don't understand.
They have a,
they have a challenge trying to
understand like what I'm doing now.
Really.
They try.
Yeah.
Like,
and they're happy that I'm,
that I'm happy,
but it's very,
you know,
they're coming from a generation where,
look,
I grew up in a really education focused
household and I tried to my best to live
up to that and to some extent I
succeeded at that.
But the whole idea was premised on this
myth of the American dream,
you know,
study hard,
get into the best school,
get into the best graduate school,
get the best job you can,
you know,
work hard and like do as you're told and
ascend the ladder and the implicit
promise,
you know,
at the end of that rainbow of course is
not only,
you know,
sort of security and prosperity but
happiness.
Yeah.
And for me,
I chased that without ever really
without those critical thinking skills
because I never really intuited that I
was just so focused on the prize and I'm
very disciplined and determined and but
I wasn't able to step outside the box
and look at it analytically in
comparison to,
you know,
what would be best for me.
Like I never said,
what do I want?
It was just,
this is what you do,
this is how you get ahead.
This is how you have a good life.
I think there's also their fault.
Sure.
No,
it's definitely not their fault.
The amount of information that they had
available to them back then comparison
to what we have today is unbelievably
different now.
There's so much more information now and
I think there's also a very.
There's a real lack of understanding of
the landscape of the race you're in.
Like everybody wants to think of it as a
race is the rat race.
But if you look,
if you could get an aerial view of the
actual race from birth to death,
from the time you're born to the time
you leave this planet.
And look at it as like you're looking
into formula one race track and you
could actually see the course.
You'd be like,
Oh fucking Jesus Christ.
What am I doing here?
I'm wasting all my time doing shit.
I don't want to do this.
Race is not very long.
This race is going to end like this is a
fuck.
I thought it.
I thought there was like a happiness
truck somewhere along the line that I
was going to refuel with and change my
tires when I get my phd.
It's the idea that you're going to
arrive at some point or that you're
going to land in this destination that
is called success or happiness.
And when you get to our age,
you realize that that's just.
That's an illusion,
right?
It just continues.
And you start to think about what your
life means.
What do you stand for and what is your
legacy?
You know,
we're approaching 50.
It's like,
what do you know if I die today,
what was,
what did I,
what did I leave in my wake?
Well,
even that,
look,
the bottom line is whatever you leave,
it's not gonna matter because it's going
to matter to some people that you know
and they're going to leave to.
Everyone's going to leave,
but are you enjoying this?
Are you enjoying the moment?
Everyone's working towards this ultimate
like the retirement years,
the golden ears like you're fucking
almost dead when those years come like
those little you see those people
holding hands and walking along,
they barely can walk.
Their knees hurt.
They're all fucked up like that's not
what you work for.
You don't work towards this ultimate
point where you don't do anything
anymore and that's ridiculous.
The what you should work towards is
doing what you enjoy doing right now and
enjoying your life right now,
enjoying your friends right now,
enjoying whatever hobbies you like to
pursue.
Whatever love affairs and friendships
and all that stuff is what life is.
Life is the moment being in the moment
and we somehow have turned it into this,
this weird journey to have a very
specific point,
specific points of high school
graduation,
college graduation,
but good job marriage,
children,
we have all these like milestones that
are supposed to impart happiness in this
race and they they're not real.
They're social constructs and we've.
We've created these social constructs
and we've fed into them and pass them
down from generation to generation
without anybody stepping back and going,
well,
who set this up?
Who set up?
Who set up graduate school?
Who said it?
Who set up?
Who set up common core?
Who?
Who are these people like,
why?
Why is,
why is it this way with this?
We're just biological organisms trying
to have as much happiness and good
feeling while we're here is we can.
I feel like that's
changing though.
I think that if you talk to somebody
who's in their twenties,
you know the idea that you would work a
corporate job and stay in that job for
your career and collect your pension and
then write out your sixties and
seventies playing golf is a foreign
concept to a young person.
Whereas that was the kind of paradigm,
right?
For our parents' generation and when you
look at the advent of the Internet and
what that provides and allows you see
this explosion in lifestyle careers
where you're not wed to a geographic
location.
We live in a kind of subcontractor
economy where people are more project
based than,
than you know,
working for the big corporation or the
plants and certainly all that stuff
exists on some level but not to the
extent that it,
that it used to.
And I think that's super interesting and
I think that allows people to engage in
critical thinking and a new and
different way.
And I think you see young people who are
asking themselves those very questions
like,
what do I want to do?
What makes me happy with that can come
entitlement.
And that's why I think the millennials
get a get a bad rap for that,
but at the same time I think that they
are much more engaged in trying to
grapple with who they are and what it is
that,
you know,
they're passionate about expressing and
then finding a way to tap into the
economy somehow so that they can
contribute and make a living doing that.
And I think that that's really cool to
watch unfold.
I agree.
And I think that the idea that
millennials are entitled,
I think every young kid has a distorted
perception of the world that we live in
and in every generation,
probably less so to know they're going
to,
they're going to be in some,
probably not on a podcast,
but in some form of media,
you know,
20 years from now talking about how,
you and I are out to lunch.
I mean that's the natural order of
things,
but how are priorities and how we raise
them,
who is myopic in some way.
Sure.
I'm sure.
Yeah,
they'll fill,
they'll figure it out.
They'll get it better than we're doing
it well with the acceleration of
technology.
I mean,
who knows where things are going to be.
We just can't foresee what the,
what that world would look like.
Yeah.
Human beings might be obsolete in 20
years.
Did you listen to the last hour of the
Sam Harris' podcast?
Artificial intelligence?
No.
I got into the first.
I think I.
I didn't make it through the end of it
the last hour and keeps me up at night.
Did you see there's a movie called x
mock and I'm going to see it tonight.
So interesting.
Half in.
It's,
it's,
it's haunting.
It's very well done.
It's a very small,
very contained independent movie,
but it's so well executed and you just
leave like with a lot to think about.
There's a lot to think about,
period.
You know,
I had a long sit down with Ray Kurzweil
and I interviewed him for the Scifi show
that I did and we went back and forth
over the possibilities of this new era
that we're entering into.
We were,
we went to,
excuse me,
this global 20,
45 initiative.
Yeah.
That they were having a New York City
where all the futurists got together and
they were all comparing notes and
talking about the different
possibilities for not just artificial
intelligence,
but symbiotic relationships with
computers,
downloading consciousness into databases
and all this kind of crazy shit.
And you walk away thinking like,
I don't,
I don't know if anybody knows where this
is going and it's not going to stop.
There's going to be continual innovation
until we reach some,
some event,
horizon of science,
some,
some point of no return,
you know,
some what they call ultimate novelty
point.
That's what Terence Mckenna used to call
it.
You know,
this ultimate novelty point and it's
probably gonna happen within our
lifetime.
It's probably going to have within the
next 20 or 30 years.
You think it's going to happen that
soon?
I mean,
I'm just guessing it's all,
it's total guessing.
Well,
there's always the issue of natural
disasters.
Any real natural disaster would throw a
massive hiccup into any plans
that anyone has.
I mean,
if all we'd need is yellowstone to blow
and it would set back civilization to
three generations easily,
if not forever.
Well,
how about just California running out of
water?
I think if we can get oil from Saudi
Arabia,
how the fuck can we not get water from
Antarctica that everybody's whining
about those,
those ice caps melting,
just stick a fucking big pipe on those
pitches and run them down to the almond
fields?
Well,
you know what's weird,
what's weird is,
uh,
is how you would think,
like if you didn't know better,
you would think how hard can it be to
desalinate the ocean?
That's got to be elementary school
chemistry,
right?
But it's interesting that it's so
difficult that the best minds are having
such a hard time figuring that out and
it's almost like the universe has rigged
it that way because human beings are
such idiots that if they made it easy,
our oceans would be dry deserts right
now because we can't help ourselves.
We cannot help ourselves.
And that is the same,
you know,
compulsion that is propelling technology
forward and will ultimately catapult us
into this ai universe that's going to
destroy us.
I,
yeah,
I think whatever it is,
why we find that funny is weird,
right?
I know,
but it is true.
If we could fucking dry out the ocean,
we would have done it a long time ago.
Those houses in Malibu who were dog
shit.
It's about $20,000,000
houses and that's not really a
$20,000,000
house.
It's just $20,000,000
because it's right there on the water.
Yeah.
That house would be worth fuck all
because there would be like a few
hundred yards of dirt in front of your
house now.
I mean how hard can it be to separate
salt from water?
Apparently.
It's pretty hard.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
they just opened up a large,
a desalination plant in San Diego.
I heard about that.
It's been over a billion dollars in this
fucker.
And then give it a run.
Right.
I just think it's a matter of time.
I mean they,
it's absolutely possible to take salt
out of water.
So I don't think that there's been as
much incentive in the past as there is
now and now that California has gone on
this three year drought where we need 11
trillion gallons of water just to bring
us back to normal.
Wow.
Well,
it's,
it's kind of emblematic of how we deal
with problems because instead of trying
to solve the problem that got us to this
place,
we're just looking for another source of
water,
right?
It's sort of like taking,
you know,
taking Viagra to deal with the fact that
you can't get a boner instead of looking
at why it is you can't get a boner.
Right?
But I mean like you're,
you're,
you're dealing with the symptom.
But there are deserts that didn't use to
be deserts.
I mean they're not because of humankind,
because that's because of natural
forces,
right?
So there is certainly one aspect of this
that you can kind of point towards human
beings,
but the reality of the earth,
the absolute reality of the earth is
climates change,
oceans,
law,
the levels change.
They always have an.
Even if people didn't exist,
you would have to deal with that.
So is there any sound like a climate,
but I'm definitely not.
All I'm saying is we have this idea that
once we're in a spot we should be able
to stay in this spot,
this spot,
but there are spots in North America.
First of all,
like half of North America was covered
in a mile of ice just 10,000
years ago.
That's a fact and we have to deal with
the fact that if we want to like set up
a house and have.
We only have five acres right here,
well guess what?
In 20 years for whatever reason,
that might not be a good spot anymore
and we have this idea that once we own
property that that spot should be
livable and ideal forever.
And even if people didn't have anything
to do with the climate,
the climate will shift,
change.
Things change.
They always will change.
We just have this really rigid idea of
like where we should be able to put
cities.
I mean,
when they keep finding these cities from
like several thousand years ago,
like did she ever see those concentric
circles that they found in the water
that they believe represents something
very similar to what Atlanta was
described as Spain outside of Spain,
they've,
they've found many,
many underground cities where at some
point in time the sea level change and
it was long before carbon emissions,
long before people were burning fossil
fuels and using machines.
It's just things shift.
It's not to exonerate large
corporations.
Cole,
our dependence on fossil fuel.
That's a totally separate argument.
I,
I absolutely think all you have to do is
look at La from a fucking airplane or
worse.
I got photos of Mexico City.
Holy Shit.
I was in Mexico City a couple months
ago.
We go to Mexico City in June.
Again for the UFC,
by the way,
nicest people.
Very,
very friendly.
Like you have this idea of Mexico City
has been like horrible crime ridden,
awful place.
It's not.
They're really nice people,
but they just need better roads.
God,
they're fucking pollution is insane.
You can taste it with your face,
like when you get out of the airplane
and you're like,
whoa,
this is crazy.
And apparently it's better than it used
to be,
whether
it's Mexico City or la,
you,
you get this really kind of potent
sense.
You see the lights and the grid and you
realize in the cars driving on the
freeway and you realize it's just an
organism.
You know,
there's these,
these freeways are carrying cars are the
arteries and the cars of the blood cells
and we're feeding these cities like
their organs in this larger unit that is
interdependent.
And it's interesting and I think it,
it,
you know,
what you said about this idea of,
of human beings and this idea that,
that we think everything is static.
I mean,
I think that applies across the board.
Like we think these cities will always
be there,
but we also think that our lives are,
are somewhat static or that our
relationships are static or our jobs or
static or
our bank accounts.
All of these things.
Um,
you know,
we kind of agreed to in this social
contract,
but everything's fluid.
Man.
You know,
everything is fluid and changing all the
time on the micro level that leads to
the macro and it's always going to be
that way.
And the also have to realize,
I think we have to realize that one of
the.
I can't find these pictures of fucking.
I think he posted that.
I don't remember when you saw my
instagram,
but the point is that the only way a
city got to be a city in the first place
is things have changed radically.
If you looked at where that city is,
he was the Los Angeles where it is 400
years ago.
There was absolutely nothing.
You know,
there's probably some native Americans
and some Mexicans and some various
people is back when it was Mexico and
they were wandering around and doing
their thing,
but there was no.
There was no highways and sky rises and
all that stuff was really,
really recent.
And in terms of the,
the actual age of the earth,
my God,
it's like blink your eye and then all of
a sudden cities are literally a blink of
an eye and then everything's polluted.
Everything's fucked.
And Malibu Beach Front property is
ridiculously overpriced,
but in the history of this planet,
has there ever been more change?
Planetary early with the exception of
natural disasters then there has been in
the last 200 years when that sense
aren't human beings as a kind of a
natural where a virus on the planet.
I mean,
come on.
That's called us.
He called caught a virus with shoes.
Yeah.
It's interesting,
mom.
The opening of my.
I'm a showtime special from like 2005.
I argued that if you looked at the earth
as a living organism and you're flying
over and you saw la,
you'd go,
well that's cancer.
That's a growth.
It's growing.
It's out of control.
It's stinks.
It looks like it's a mess and it's
getting bigger.
We're greedy.
Bastards were lacking that gene that
prioritizes doing things sustainably.
I think it's a huge problem.
We're predatory.
We're not symbiotic well.
I think we have an an inescapable thirst
for innovation.
We want new and better things and we
want progress.
And of course short sighted in that
regard.
We are,
we don't,
we,
we're unable to see the bigger picture.
We don't have the foresight to,
to make the responsible decision quite
often,
quite often.
Well we,
we,
we err towards the size of prop started
toward the side of profit and success
and I oftentimes at the expense of,
what is that you think?
I mean other animals,
other animals don't have that.
Those,
even though they do though they do
beavers fuck up dams and they create
dams and ruined rivers.
They don't make beaver city says they
can now they could,
they would get together and you know,
if they can chew more huge giant dam and
the Mississippi River,
if they can agree with each other and
they would do it,
they don't give a fuck about,
you know what I mean?
Bears Shit.
Wherever they walk,
they don't,
they don't clean up,
they don't have like a certain spot
where they put all their shit.
They just don't have enough of an impact
to really change the environment around
them.
But if they could,
they would.
Uh,
I was listening to a radio lab podcast
about the Galapagos Islands and it's
very fascinating because they had to
eradicate goats because these sailors
had brought goats over,
you know,
way back in the day and they had brought
goats and they put them on the island so
that they could come back and eat them,
like they would have a food source,
but these goats just destroy everything
in their path.
They just killed everything and they
fucked it all up for the tortoise's.
These poor tortoise's we're fucked.
They didn't have any plant matter
anymore because all these goats were
coming along.
So then they hired these people to kill
the goats.
So they flew over and helicopters and
they gunned down the goats and then God
started getting smart.
So what they do was they would find
goats.
They would capture them,
they would put radio collars on them,
they would scare them.
They would run over to where the other
goats were,
and then they would find where the goats
were.
They would kill all of them except the
ones with the radio collars.
And so they became what they called
Judas goats.
It's really fascinating how they set
this up and then it got to a point where
it was nothing but Judas goats.
That's all that was left.
And so then,
you know,
they tried to reintroduce tortoise's is
really,
really fascinating.
But the argument could be made that any
animal acting purely in its own interest
will ultimately fuck up everything
around it.
And it's one of the reasons why there's
gotta be some kind of a balance,
has got to be some kind of a balance
between humans and the plants that we
coexist with and the animals that we
coexist with.
And the same can be said with animals,
like,
you know,
you can't have too many predators in an
area.
You can't have too many,
uh,
too many deer in an area.
You're run into them with cars,
they start starving to death.
You get ticks and people start spreading
the.
They start spreading lyme disease and
there's like humans and animals and they
all act in their own interest.
It's just we're the only ones that have
finger.
Well,
we can manipulate shit and change the
environment in ways that no other animal
could even come close to.
There is an infinitely complex,
you know,
play that's going on and we insert
ourselves into that and we have this
reductionist idea,
oh,
if we insert this one thing,
then that will fix the problem and what
we don't do is really understand that,
that the,
the,
the extent to which the Inter dependency
of everything else comes into play.
And I think that's true whether you're
introducing an animal to an ecology to
solve a problem and it creates a bigger
problem or whether you're taking a drug
to resolve one condition that has side
effects or whether you're overly focused
on one micronutrient or macronutrient as
the solution to your health problem.
You know,
everything is more complicated than
that.
And I don't think that we kind of
embrace a more holistic approach to,
you know,
whether it's our problems or our health
or,
or what have you.
That's another thing.
It's not part of our wiring and it's not
part of the,
you know,
the scientific method is by definition
reductionist because you have to isolate
variables and look at one thing at a
time.
It's true.
That's very true.
It's very true.
Science in and of itself is reductionist
and I think that there's also this weird
hope that people have that have like,
we fuck something up.
Then our backs get against the wall.
Then someone really smart will invent a
solution and it'll all be better.
You know that someone like right now is
analyzing the who knows how many fucking
trillions of pounds of plastic we've
dumped into the ocean and they're trying
to figure out some way to suck all that
stuff out and turn it into some sort of
fuel or some resource that we can
capitalize on.
That's those.
Those,
those kinds of thinking or that kind of
thinking is real common.
We always think that eventually someone
smarter,
we'll figure out a way out of this mess.
Elan Musk,
it's going to solve it for all of us.
Right,
and I think that he might.
I think that part of that is just the
level of disenfranchisement that the
average person has.
Like we just don't feel like our vote
counts.
We don't feel like our dollar counts and
like fuck it,
you know,
dancing with the stars is on and like I
can't make a difference so I'm gonna
throw my garbage out the window and who
cares?
I just found out the dancing with the
stars have been on for 10 years has it?
I've never watched a single episode.
I really have never.
I've been flipping through the channels
and I saw some people dancing and
everybody cheering and I was like,
what in the actual fuck?
And I change the channel again.
Like you were watching people dance now.
Really?
Like nobody likes to dance like that.
That was like,
okay then that will.
Isn't that what like Mexican TV was
dancing with his door as well as like,
you know,
you turn on like when we were kids it
was like,
it was all song and dance,
you know,
and the Spanish television shows Spanish
network.
I thought it was all those crazy soap
operas.
Yeah,
that too.
But that's what reality TV is,
right?
We've regressed in some ways while
there's a part of us that really we
really love base things,
you know,
we love emotions.
Like I was just thinking of this the
other day,
the talk show host like um,
like a Morton Downey jr or Jenny Jones
or,
or Geraldo Rivera,
any of those shows or like Montel
Williams where they would have guests
and then they would go to the audience
and the audience would like say
something that would get everybody to go
like that,
that thing that they created,
that parent.
Those are like the original Youtube
commenters.
There's like the original,
like social media commentators,
the people that are in the audience,
they don't have anything to do with
what's on it,
but they get to interject and say
something and then that becomes a part
of the entertainment.
But it's really just,
you know,
it's weird social interaction between
human beings and us,
like sitting as sidelines.
What are you showing?
Oh yeah,
of course.
Sure.
Springer,
he's the master of that.
What a crazy way to make a living.
Right?
I mean,
when that guy was a character.
Yeah.
Is he still is?
He's still alive,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He's actually a very intelligent guy.
He wasn't even mayor prize land or
something like that.
And he got in troubles and prostitution.
Cincinnati,
there's a little.
I think there was a little cocaine
problem at one blow,
but you know,
we,
we enjoy those stupid moments that don't
mean anything.
You know,
where someone says something and
everybody goes,
oh,
there's nothing wrong.
There's nothing wrong with a guilty
pleasure.
You know what I mean?
Not necessarily.
Look,
you can't fix the world.
You can't be captain.
Save a hoe and go out there and fix the
whole world.
Now go to the Jerry springer crowd and
start hanging out Kale leaves and you
know,
pamphlets for yoga classes snuck in a
word.
Are you talking about the ego?
Talking about everybody,
like I eat Kale to dude,
it is a thing,
man.
If you,
um,
if you've ever mocked like very,
uh,
just,
just really ridiculous proselytizing
vegans,
which I have people think all of a
sudden just like vegans,
they think I don't like them or don't
eat that food.
I eat that food.
Almost always I eat more vegetables that
I eat meat.
I way more vegetables.
I eat a lot of it.
I think it's good for you.
Well,
vegans are an easy target that you guys
are easiest phone.
I mean,
so uh,
but you're not,
you're,
you're like,
you're like the.
If all vegans were like,
you,
there would be no target because like
people who just eat healthy,
that's it.
You're just someone who enjoys eating
plants instead of animal products and
that's just,
that's just your diet.
It doesn't become a fucking religion
with you.
I mean,
look,
first of all it's not,
it's not my place to,
to pass judgment on anybody else in.
There are behavior patterns in their
habits and you know,
I'm not,
I'm not trying to,
you know,
recruit people to my lifestyle,
if people want to ask me about it,
I'm happy to talk about it.
But I'm not like yelling from a bully
pulpit,
you know,
shaming people or the shaming I have.
No,
I have no,
you know,
air of moral superiority about it
whatsoever.
It's a,
it's a lifestyle that I choose,
but I don't think that,
um,
that gives me permission to,
Levy judgment on any other human being
and,
and their choices.
So,
you know,
the way that I try to communicate the
message is to,
to,
you know,
live my life and you know,
sort of stand where I'm standing and if
people are interested and they'll come
to me and,
and you know,
I can communicate to them.
But um,
but it's,
you know,
it's not a proselytizing point of view
that I adopt.
I think some
people adopt certain behaviors just
because it gives them license to be an
asshole.
I really do.
I mean there are certain vegans that
think that because they are vegans,
they can go out and attack and be really
shitty to other people and somehow or
another they're acting in a positive way
and they're going to enact some positive
change by being really shitty to people.
It's like this idea of a social justice
warrior falls into the same category by
being really mean to people that you
think,
think the wrong way or behave the wrong
way,
that somehow or another you're going to
shame them into changing by being really
aggressive and offensive to them.
I mean,
shaming somebody is not an effective way
of trying to getting them to change one
of the least effective.
I mean,
look,
people change when they're ready to
change,
you know,
it's really an internal willingness that
drives change and you know,
somebody is either ready to make a
change or they're not.
And,
and different people receive messages in
different ways.
So if you look at,
look,
if you look at the Vegan movement,
because that's what we're talking about,
you know,
there are super hardcore animal rights
activists and they have a certain way of
communicating and there's a certain
population of people that are receptive
to that kind of communication.
There are other people that are
interested in environmental issues.
They want to be better
environmentalists.
And so there are people that speak to
the Vegan movement from that
perspective.
Um,
and,
and there's a certain audience that's
receptive to that and the way that I
communicated or carry the message is in
a different way.
And there's,
you know,
different people that are attracted to
that.
So I think whatever your,
your point of view is or whatever
movement you're part of and that we can
get into the whole idea of how we're
wired to be on teams and how
counterproductive that is.
But,
um,
you know,
there's enough people out there that
are,
uh,
you know,
there's a diversity of voices and a
diversity of,
of audiences that,
you know,
every,
every kind of voice carries a frequency
that,
that other people respond to.
I guess I didn't say that very
articulately,
but I know what you're saying though,
you know,
there,
there are definitely going to be,
there's no one that responds well to
being insulted though.
No one.
I mean,
if you're really trying to convey a
message being really shitty about it is
the last thing.
Well look at,
look at political talk shows on Saturday
and Sunday morning and they're just
shouting at each other and and basically
they're just rallying support from their
base.
Each side they're trying to win,
but they're not,
they're not converting people from one
side to the other.
No one ever gets converted.
The only way to have anybody ever gets
converted as like,
if you can say something very thoughtful
that penetrates past this wall of
ideology they have in their head and
they go and then they have to consider
it,
but they're not going to consider if
you're insulting.
They're just not.
It's going to be a contest.
It's going to be a you versus them.
You say something rude to them.
They're going to try say something rude
or to you and you're,
you're playing ping pong,
ping pong,
ping pong with insults.
And to be clear like,
you know,
I'm a member of this community and you
know,
I am a proud member,
I would say.
And you a card carrying member.
I have the card in my wallet because
it'll leaf is a leaf.
It's in that juicy ladies.
Glasses don't have cards,
we just carry us here.
You know,
my theory on it,
the people that are,
that are kind of,
you would characterize as vociferous and
angry and judgmental.
My theory is that there's a certain
percentage of the population that come
out of the womb.
I'm broken.
Well,
there's that.
Okay.
So there's that.
Of course,
you know,
there are those people for sure.
And there are other people that I think
are wired to be super sensitive.
Sure.
And from a very early age,
they just find the idea of,
you know,
an animal dying for food to be the most
intolerable concept they can imagine.
Right?
And they're just,
that's,
that's how they came into the world.
Right?
And so,
and so they kind of grow older and they
navigate the world and they start,
you know,
becoming sort of more outspoken about
this idea and when people are not
receptive to it or they're not seeing
the world the way that they're seeing
it,
they become progressively more
frustrated.
And that frustration turns to
resentment.
That resentment can morph into anger and
then you know,
you have what you see which is,
which is people who are,
they're just,
they're just incensed that other people
are not seeing the world the way that
they're seeing it.
And I think that applies to any
contingent of the population that holds
a very strong point of view.
I,
I agree with you.
I think that there's,
there,
there's definitely going to be certain
people that are hardwired for
sensitivity.
There's just no getting around it and
you realize that when you have children,
you know,
I have two young daughters that are so
different.
They're only two years apart from each
other,
grew up in the same household.
They could not be more different.
Right.
It's just right out of the box.
They're just different people.
Yeah.
You realize like he had nothing to do
with that.
Yeah.
I mean
you have a little bit to do with how
they,
how they process things and how they
deal with things based on learned
that innate core kind of perspective and
whatever they're naturally inclined to
is just,
you can see it at such a young age.
Yeah,
that's the difference,
right?
The difference is like what,
what is a real part of them?
What is a real part of them?
Like what,
what,
what is just inescapable.
Like they have certain ingredients like
a car is made out of aluminum and rubber
and metal.
There's certain ingredients that certain
people have when they're born and also
inclinations,
inclinations towards certain activities
like we were talking about before,
like trying to find things that make
your children happy and try and
encourage things that make your children
happy to find a thing that they like
that jives with their ingredients.
And some people
they look at animals and they just have
this inescapable in this capable kinship
and some of the,
someone that kinship is ridiculous.
The point where he ever read those
tumblr blogs where people think that
there should have been born a fox,
have fox,
can you never seen that?
That sounds like something red band
which spent a lot of time doing with
thinking he used to be just being,
you know,
being on like weird tumblr sites.
Um,
we're tumblr sites can get very
addictive.
You wonder whether or not you're being
trolled,
you know,
some of them are so weird.
You wonder like,
okay,
so this is this real,
you know?
Yeah.
I don't know.
Fox can you never heard of that?
No,
I haven't to look around at people that
they,
they believe that they should have been
born as foxes.
Yes.
Okay.
They believe their Fox came spirit open
minded thinker.
There's other dimensions that play.
You saw interstellar I didn't see in
yourself that you didn't know.
I haven't seen it yet.
I'm fucking busy,
Bro.
Uh,
but the,
um,
the idea is just,
that's a ridiculous idea.
But I also think that there's also
people that have this very idealistic
idea of animals and nature itself,
which is,
hey,
there's some videos we've been shown
recently with a deer that are eating
birds,
eating birds alive,
which apparently is a recent discovery
that deer are not really just
herbivores.
They're herbivores by convenience,
but when they find a birds on the
ground,
they eat them and they seek them out.
They actually chased them.
Is that a result of encroaching habitat
by urban centers or no?
No.
These are wild beer in very rural areas
there have been observed to.
It's uh,
apparently they're getting minerals and
stuff from,
from deer,
from a bird's brother,
and um,
they're more inclined to do so when
they're growing their antlers.
They feel,
you know,
more,
uh,
more drawn to eating birds.
That's interesting.
I didn't know that.
Yeah,
there's a bunch of videos.
It's kind of disturbing because you,
you know,
even though I'm a hunter and I eat deer,
I think they're beautiful and I always
think of him as being these peaceful
things and we see them chasing a bird
and just chewing it alive and fucking
things kicking inside of their mouth and
trying to get away.
Well,
they're just,
they're part of the,
you know,
natural cycle of life.
They're just trying to survive like
everything else.
And I think,
you know,
I think to the casual observer,
or somebody who's listening to this
podcast,
they may think that there's this giant
gap between the way that you live in a
way that I live.
And I think there's actually a bigger
gap between the way that I live in,
in the normal human being than yourself
because of,
you know,
look,
you're a hunter.
I don't hunt,
you know,
it's not something that I'm interested
in doing,
but you have a connection to where your
food is coming from that is very,
um,
close and primal.
And,
and in the grand scheme of things more
sustainable than the way that,
you know,
the average typical American,
it's kind of more sustainable.
But honestly,
not
for everybody.
The reality,
not everybody could do it,
you know,
not everybody can do it.
I mean,
I think that,
that right now our food system is
broken.
You know,
our,
our system of factory farming.
It's unsustainable.
I actually brought you this documentary
called cowspiracy spirits.
Oh,
cowspiracy.
Yeah.
I was involved in a producing this
movie.
You should check it out.
But basically it's a look at,
at the impact of animal agriculture on
our environment.
And it's hard.
It's pretty interesting.
Did you see that,
that video that they got a drone video
of these gigantic pig farms and the just
the fucking unbelievable environmental
catastrophe these things create.
Would they have lakes of piss and shit
from these pigs?
It's different.
Have you seen it now?
Haven't you really should see it and
perceiving it?
Pull that video up,
Jamie,
because it's.
It's insane to look at.
When you stop and think about the,
the,
the amount of Smithfield foods,
factory farms.
That's it right there.
If this guy flies his drone,
which is pretty fucking cool that they
have these drones now that you could do
this and get this high resolution video.
Well if you're dealing with a place like
Los Angeles,
$20,
million people,
20 million people and 95 percent of the
meat meat,
you're dealing with an insane amount of
flash that needs to be consumed on a
daily basis and it has to be grown
somewhere and ship somewhere and
conveniently.
We want to sort of ignore it like that
is a lake of shit and piss and it's all
coming from these factories right there
in front of you.
Those are housing units for pigs,
they're stuffed into these things
crammed next to each other and they
stand on these metal grates.
So the metal grates are poorest.
They piss and shit.
It goes through the holes and it all
goes through these tubes that lead down
into that giant lake.
Apparently the smell,
if you're anywhere near there is so bad.
You literally feel like you could
probably like the air on fire.
I'm sure Smithfield,
Smithfield is not too excited about this
video being out there and you know,
there's all these ag gag laws right now
that prevent consumers from filming this
kind of thing.
So that's insane that he's been able to
do this with a drone and you know,
whether you're,
you know,
whether you eat bacon for breakfast
every morning or you eat more like me.
I think we can all agree that,
that transparency is important and these
companies are not transparent about how
they produce their food and there's a
lot of problems with it and the waste
that it creates and the amount of
resources and you know,
what goes into this process is something
that I think we could all benefit from
taking a harder look at.
You know,
it'd be interesting is if you go to the
um,
cowspiracy website,
they have all these facts about kind of,
you know,
every sort of environmental of,
of
what animal agriculture does from water
use to see co two emissions to land use
to species extinction to rainforest
destruction.
And when you look at the statistics,
it's,
it's crazy.
It's absolutely crazy.
It's like the elephant in the room,
you know,
we talk about when we talk about global
climate change or,
or greenhouse gas emissions,
we talk about,
we talk about fossil fuel use,
we talk about fracking and rightly so.
These are important things to talk
about.
But really the thing that we're not
talking enough about is the impact of,
of our food system on all of these
systems.
And when you look at,
for example,
water use,
we're talking about water,
right?
Well,
you know there's PSA is in California,
we're not supposed to take long showers,
we can't water our lawns,
all these sorts of things.
And the truth is is that consumer water
use in California is like five percent
and animal agriculture accounts for like
55 percent of all water use.
And you know what a bonus.
You know what the really big useless one
is?
Well,
golf quality horses.
Well animal agriculture,
trump's golf courses,
at least animal agriculture is like
feeding animals at,
right?
Right.
You just feeding fuck right.
Dude's rolling balls around on the
grass.
That's an insane,
insane amount of water for your
amusement.
Yeah.
I think it takes something like 660
gallons of water to produce a hamburger
and like a thousand gallons of milk or a
thousand gallons of water to produce one
gallon of milk.
Something like that.
Like the,
the statistics are completely insane and
that.
Because a lot of it is the water that's
used to grow the grain that you're
feeding to these animals.
So when you look at it systemically,
you know,
it's just,
it doesn't like if you were an alien who
beamed down to planet earth and said,
take me to your leader and show me how
you make your food.
He would just be like,
you guys are crazy.
You're like killing the planet to do
this,
doesn't it?
Doesn't.
It doesn't make sense.
Not Sustainable in the longterm.
If we did it exactly the way we're doing
it right now forever.
Would that be sustainable?
I don't think so.
Can we can do it right now?
Well,
I mean we're.
The way that we're doing it right now.
I mean we're destroying like rain forest
like crazy,
right?
It's like one to two acres,
like every hour or something like that.
Isn't that.
A lot of it is due to their,
they're getting exotic hardwoods and all
these different and saw lumbering and
there's some of that for sure.
And there's palm oil and there's other
things like that.
But I think the gravity men,
like the majority of it goes to grazing
land and growing crops for,
for livestock.
And this is other countries.
This is not America,
America Amazonian rain forest.
We're not cutting down the rainforest in
America and we're not getting our beef
from there either,
but I think,
you know,
like an insane amount of our total land
mass is devoted to,
is devoted to animal agriculture too.
So,
you know,
it's like billions of these animals that
were specifically raising to eat,
you know,
and it's,
it's a,
it's a huge,
it's a huge problem.
It is a huge problem.
That is something that is outside of
your normal
thinking,
normal everyday thinking you're getting
on the highway,
goddammit.
There's traffic today.
You're getting to work.
Oh Great.
We've got this new project we have to
deal with and you're,
you're,
you're real existence.
Like all that stuff is bullshit.
If you don't have any food,
all that traffic,
all the work stuff like,
hey,
you're gonna die.
You don't have any food.
Like this is like here's,
here's a bunch of things that you need
to have in place before you think about
any other hobbies or projects or
whatever you're trying to accomplish
with your career.
You got to have a place where you can
breathe.
The air,
okay,
the air has to be clean.
That's one on the ocean,
has to be hospitable for fish and plant
life for us.
Well,
if you're a Vegan,
you really don't need to worry about
anything other than the plant life in
the ocean if you're only kelp,
but actually calculate a very good
source of protein.
That goes back to this reductionist
idea,
right?
These are complex ecosystems,
so you knock one thing out in the ocean
and the domino effect of that,
you know like these,
the runoff that's caused from waste
animal agriculture is a big one.
There's all kinds of ways.
Just Susan the ocean,
and it creates these massive dead zone
dead zones.
The Algal blooms,
right?
That deprives them like,
like thousands of acres worth across the
ocean that are so oxygen deprived that
nothing can live in them.
Well,
there was a big die off when I was in
her most a beach a couple of years ago.
They had a giant fish die off where it
was.
Oh,
so fucking stinky.
It was so nasty.
Wash up on the shore.
Well,
I think they just died like in certain
bays,
you know,
there was an,
an area where they just hit a dead zone
and a bunch of fish died and supernormal
very common happens all the time and it
smelled so bad.
It was just,
you know,
probably a fucking million dead fish or
something.
I'll.
Yeah,
awful.
But when we're.
So what we're getting at,
but.
But I mean,
yeah,
I mean as you know,
as typical consumers were,
were divorced from that.
That's not in our face.
You know what I mean?
Like we're not really,
we don't have to reckon with that on a
daily basis,
is it possible that like,
could you have an entire city of 20
million people?
You couldn't have an entire city of 20
million people that lived as hunters.
You really couldn't.
You would need more animals.
But could you have an entire city of 20
million people that were Vegan?
Oh yeah.
I mean,
I,
I think that,
that the amount of land that you need to
grow food for vegans is like,
you know,
I don't know,
a fraction,
a tiny fraction of the amount of land
that is required to raise animals for
food because the animals have to eat a
lot of food in order to get to a size.
I mean,
you need,
you need tons of grazing land and,
and you know,
like if you go to go to cowspiracy.com
and there's a section called facts and
they kind of break it all down.
It's kind of interesting to look at.
Um,
but,
but yeah,
I mean I think that,
that the amount of land,
like we're producing enough food to feed
the planet really.
It's really like an allocation and
distribution issue as much as any
meeting we use like American,
but most of the food that we're growing
in the bread basket of America is going
to livestock.
It's not going to human beings.
I mean like the corn fields,
they're also making that core and that's
really not even edible for humans.
That,
uh,
you see you saw king corn?
Uh,
yeah,
I did.
It's amazing,
amazing documentary.
We're all like made out of fucking crazy
when they,
when they do the tests on their body and
they find out that the carbon for core
and then human,
the carbon in their body is coming from
corn.
If you find out how much,
how many different things at the
supermarket when they went through the
supermarket,
they looked at all the different things
that have corn syrup and corn starch,
corn,
this corn that.
It's like,
wow,
how did that happen?
How did they hijack the entire food
system?
I mean,
you don't write amazing.
He'd fucking corn,
you know,
like all that stuff that they're using
corn for is not really necessary,
but you can profit off of it if you own
the corn and if you have some sort of a
relationship with the government,
you can get a subsidy subsidy's and
that's what happens.
They're,
they're being fed off subsidies.
That's one of the things that was most
disturbing about it.
Like,
wait a minute,
this is so destructive and this is.
And you guys couldn't even afford to
grow this shit if it wasn't for the
government.
If the government didn't pay corn
farmers,
they didn't have government subsidies,
a lot of them would just go under.
Yeah,
I mean I think that we're,
we're entrenched in this system that is
dependent upon these subsidies.
Right?
And so much of our economy functions in
this way.
And I think if we really want to change
our food system,
we have to eradicate these subsidies.
And when you look at,
you know,
look,
there's a reason why.
I think we talked about this last time.
I can't remember.
There's a reason why like Taco Bell Taco
is like whatever it is,
dollar and nine cents or whatever.
And it's like it's the same price.
It was when we were 12.
Like how does that work?
You know,
a Mcdonald's cheeseburger is like two
bucks or whatever it is.
But if you factor in,
like if you look at it from a Meta
perspective and you take into account
all the subsidies,
you know,
a big Mac would actually cost something
like 7:50
or you know,
it'd be like a multiple on its price.
There's a book called metagenomics by
this guy called David Simon where he,
I'm sorry,
meet and Omics,
and he really breaks down how these
subsidies work and how that kind of
fuels this food system that really is
creating it.
It's sort of,
it's,
it's making the,
the,
um,
the lower socioeconomic class,
like less and less healthy because it's
creating this wider gap between healthy
living and unhealthy living because in
food deserts,
in urban food deserts where there is no
farmer's market,
but there's Mcdonald's and Jack in the
box on every corner and you know,
you're on welfare and you got three
kids,
like,
what are you going to do?
Right?
You're going to eat shitty food is too
cheap to not.
That's a really good point.
That's a really good point as far as the
amount that it costs
for these things and that the fact that
it's because of subsidies as a result of
that we're in this place right now where
suddenly health and wellness have become
elitist ideals,
you know,
synonymous with,
spending a ton of money at whole foods
and that's crazy.
Are you opposed to eating like chicken
eggs,
like from someone who grows chickens and
has them like free ranging and you know,
like I have chickens that they,
they lay eggs every day and they're,
they're essentially my pets.
I eat,
I eat my pet's food,
you know,
I feed them,
they eat a lot of the table scraps but
they,
a lot of them,
they just free range.
They run around eating stuff in the
grass and bugs and from like an ethical
point of view,
you know,
if you're raising your own chickens and
they're like your pets and they're
laying eggs that are not going to be,
you know,
turn into chickens than I think
ethically I don't really see a problem
with that.
You know what I mean?
Like like they're not going to,
you know,
they're not going to knock those eggs,
are not going to turn into chickens,
but Peter has this thing on their
website about eggs being chicken periods
and they're trying to discourage people
from eating eggs.
Have you ever seen it?
It's hilarious.
It's one of those things where it just
shows you like the.
There's,
there's ethical considerations when it
comes to livestock and animals that are
there.
They've rational,
they make sense.
And then you get into this extreme
animal rights ideology where they try to
twist reality and so they have like a
bloody bloody pair of underwear and a
chicken.
Like here it is.
Look at this.
Eggs come from chicken menstruation.
So they're frying a bloody pair of
underwear in a frying pan.
Don't eat eggs period.
And the word period is red,
like period blood.
I mean this is the stage of my Peta.
They're very effective at marketing.
They were talking while we're talking
about it right now,
we're talking about how retarded they
are.
I eat seven more eggs today just because
of these assets.
That's not,
that's not like effective.
If you're.
If,
if you have chickens at your home and
they're your pets and your kids play
with them and they're laying eggs that
are not going to turn into chickens and
you decide that you want to eat those
eggs from a,
from a morality point of view,
like how can I.
I don't,
I don't really see how I could have a
big problem with that.
Now if you decide that you want to cut
the head off that chicken and fry it up,
then then when it comes up because well
it's becomes a different thing.
Right?
Becomes different than becomes a
different thing.
What was the last time he ate meat?
So it's been awhile.
I went to,
you went vegan and it's been,
has been eight years coming up on nine
maybe.
Wow.
Do you ever smell like your neighbor
cooking a steak and go,
yeah,
I mean,
you know,
I'm not one of those people who's like,
oh,
it repulses me and I
want to throw up,
you know,
like I got into it for health reasons.
Right.
And you know,
I listened.
I've eaten more meat in my lifetime than
any human being ever should,
you know,
it's like I'm not,
I like it,
you know,
I drive by Mcdonald's or Jack in the box
and I smell that and that we might
discuss some people,
but it triggers like this addictive
response in me where it's like,
I will crave that,
you know,
because there's so much time has passed
between me and eating those foods.
I don't have that,
that sort of obsessive compulsive thing
that kicks in.
Like I'm also,
I'm a recovering alcoholic,
like I have.
Um,
I'm like,
you know,
I can get addicted to things pretty
fucking easy.
Right?
So that's part of my thing,
like for me to draw a lot,
uh,
you know,
kind of a line in the sand and say like,
no more is kind of the way that I have
to do it right,
because otherwise it inhabits my
consciousness too much.
But you have to put up boundaries where
the unsurmountable boundaries,
there are certain diets that say,
Oh,
you can have a cheat day.
Right?
So it's like if you told me that I could
have in and out burger like once a week,
like I would,
I would spend six days thinking about
the day that I could have in and out
burger.
You know what I mean?
Like in order to free myself from that
prison,
I need time away.
Right.
So,
you know,
it's,
it's really powerful with me,
whether it's a cheeseburger or a drink
or a drug,
you know,
and that's just me,
it's just my experience.
But when I smelled that,
yeah,
triggers that thing,
I'm like,
oh,
that's good,
but if it passes quickly,
but if I was eating those things,
I might find myself driving into the
drive through.
You know,
that's an issue with people that have
eating disorders where the.
It's almost like the,
the,
the desire to have that forbidden food
overwhelms their desire to be healthy.
It's like that,
that it just becomes this thing like
I've got,
I've got an itch it,
I've got an Itch,
itchy,
I got to scratch it.
I can't help it.
Yeah.
Transcends logic and it becomes
psychological.
It becomes a psychological issue way
more than it is a physiological issue.
It's almost beyond psychology though,
like it's so embedded now for anybody
who's truly like an addict or an
alcoholic like it.
It goes to the core,
you know,
there is no overriding it.
When that kicks in,
it's just,
it's happening.
I had a friend who was on the Atkins
Diet and my friend Eddie Bravo,
he was on the Atkins Diet and he would
do it for six days a week and then
midnight on Saturday night that mother
fucker would go off the rails like a
runaway train piloted by a meth addict.
Oh my God.
You.
What do you intuit for?
What do you intuit from that?
Right.
Like he's building a lot of ways.
He loaded up all week.
So it worked though.
But why would you.
I'm not saying that an atkins diet is a
healthy diet because I don't think it
is,
but,
but what's wrong an atkins diet,
if you
could say so from an.
Well,
I mean I'm not a nutritional scientists
dots or you know,
I would say that that,
that I'm a diet that's super focused on
basically excluding anything with any
carbohydrates in it and eating foods
that are devoid of any fiber,
which I think is really important.
We talk about protein a lot,
but I think most people,
I think that conversation should really
be about fiber,
like nobody's protein deficient.
I think three percent of the population
has protein deficient.
Most Americans are fiber deficient
though we just don't eat enough
vegetables.
But as the atkins diet fiber deficient
manner did they tell you can eat
broccoli.
I think that they.
I think that there a,
there is a focus on,
on meat and dairy products,
right?
It's like,
I mean I'm not an expert on the,
on the atkins diet sort of.
Yeah.
It's like being in Ketosis and you know,
that's a very,
you know,
hot button thing and you know,
there are people that are all about like
being in Ketosis and my understanding of
that is that it's kind of a crisis state
for the human body.
It's not a natural state of being,
it's sort of like what your body has to
do when it's being deprived of other
nutrients to be in this state.
Like you put these acid ketones in your
body,
which then are converted to some form of
Glucose because you're so glucose
deprived,
right?
Our brains run on Glucose or bodies need
glucose.
You know,
if you look at,
look at,
you know,
the longest living pockets,
the pockets of civilization across the
world where people live the longest and
are the healthiest in are the happiest.
Like the blue zones you've heard of the
blue zones,
right?
So Dan Buettner,
who's the guy who traveled to all of
these places,
it was a friend of mine's amazing guy.
You should have them on the podcast.
He's amazing.
What's his name?
Dan Buettner be you be you e t,
t e n e r,
he's a national geographic fellow.
He's so impressive.
He's what's his,
uh,
his uh,
well he's,
he's the guy who wrote the blue zones
books.
So he,
he was,
uh,
like a global adventurer who set like
three world records,
like cycling across the planet doing all
these crazy things and,
and cycling.
Well,
he rode his bike across Africa,
like north to south,
I think,
what the fuck you wrote across Russia
like when this was,
when he was younger and then,
uh,
you know,
he became interested in indigenous
populations.
He started working with National
Geographic.
He became a writer and a,
and in his travels he became obsessed
with finding places where people are the
happiest,
live,
the longest free of disease,
et Cetera.
And that ultimately became what are
today known as the blue zones.
Like these,
like these little sort of hidden pockets
on the planet that are kind of untouched
from the gestalt of our modern society
and you know,
they're little tiny places kind of off
the beaten path.
I,
you know,
Eco,
the,
uh,
which is like an island off the coast of
Turkey,
Sardinia,
Okinawa,
and ironically Loma Linda here,
like not too far from here.
And so the Loma Linda,
which is pretty interesting.
Yeah.
And that's at work.
It's
a cultural thing because it's a
community of seventh day adventists and
it's a very strong faith based community
that also basically subsist on a plant
based diet and they live in.
They live incredibly long.
There you go.
So the seven day adventist adventist,
seventh day adventist,
it's weird word.
They are live.
Say it.
Even if you're saying it correctly,
it seems like you're doing it wrong and
it's a very strong faith based community
and they a based diet,
physical activity,
social engagement,
social engagement support and huge.
It's huge.
And,
and,
and so,
so from,
from studying these cultures,
he extracted certain kind of guiding
principles about how they live their
life and one of them to get back to the
question about kind of Atkins Diet is,
you know,
they all eat a very starchy,
um,
you know,
fiber rich essentially plant based diet
doesn't mean they're all vegans like
the,
a little bit of meat.
But essentially their diet is founded
upon starchy vegetables for the most
part.
And,
and community and accountability and
kind of keeping your elders around and
all these sorts of things have really,
you know,
distinguishes them as a,
from the way that we live our lives now,
right?
Like,
you know,
we're just,
we're,
we're isolated,
we're fast paced and all these sorts of,
you know,
kind of principles upon which we
navigate our day or just very divorced
from the way that these people are
living.
I love that it says empowered women.
Empowered women is a factor in age.
That's,
that's fascinating.
I wonder what that's about.
A big part of it too.
I had Dan on my podcast,
so if people are listening,
they can,
they can check him out.
He was great.
But he,
uh,
a big part of it too is,
um,
is having purpose,
like sort of identifying early on in
your life,
uh,
you know,
what your purpose is and,
and serving that purpose.
And these people don't retire,
you know,
they're just,
they're sort of,
you know,
living and continuing to be productive
like way later in life than we're used
to seeing enjoying your time here and
that positive energy.
That's attached to enjoying your time
here,
sustains your existence in a much better
way.
Yeah.
Sort of.
Sort of low grade exercise.
These people,
you know,
they're always moving,
they're not out running.
They're not on the treadmill,
but they're in their garden and they're
walking to their friend's house and you
know,
they're very engaged with their
community.
They're constantly very intimate way.
Yeah.
Do you know I had a Aubrey de Grey on
the other day who's a life extension
scientist as a,
at the forefront of the various
technologies are being developed to
extend life.
He said the difference between the
average and these cultures where they
live far longer is four years.
That's the big goal that everybody's
trying to attain.
Like live like these people that
live the longest and that's four years.
Four.
There's a four year difference,
right?
Well I think,
you know,
in these blue zones they have the
highest percentage per capita of
centenarians.
People living longer than 100,
but I think it's less about that age
than it is about the quality of,
of your years.
Right.
Like,
you know,
listen,
go to the airport and look at how many
people are in wheelchairs and you know,
on walkers and stuff like that.
People that are not old go to
Disneyland.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
Do you ever go to Disneyland people on
Scooters overflowing out of the side of
the scooters with their legs and their
gut and just who?
Oh right.
So right now in America,
you know,
we can split hairs over,
should you take fish oil or not,
or is it okay for you to eat the eggs
from your chicken and your backyard?
But the truth is this is not the problem
that we need to be talking about.
We need to be talking about the fact
that one out of every three Americans is
going to die of a heart attack and 70
percent of Americans are obese or
overweight and they're predicting that
by 20,
30,
50 percent of Americans are going to be
diabetic or prediabetic.
Just think about that is that real
20,
30,
50 percent of Americans are going to be
diabetic or prediabetic diabetes.
Fucking insane.
One out of it.
Every three people is going to die of
heart disease.
Heart disease is a lifestyle and
foodborne illness.
It doesn't have to exist and we're in
this place right now where it's sort of
like some congenital verge there.
There,
there is for sure,
but that's not worth.
But if you look back through the history
of mankind,
there are plenty of populations that
existed for hundreds and thousands of
years without any significant incidence
of heart disease,
you know,
especially in rural areas of China for
long,
long years until we started exporting
our diet and lifestyle overseas and now,
you know,
it's sort of like the latest installment
of the avengers,
you know,
we're sending these fast food
restaurants to these places and they're
having,
they're having and as the sort of
ascension of the middle class in China,
you know,
continues and they can afford to
purchase more meat products.
They're having a heart problem.
They are having disease problems that
they've,
they haven't seen.
You know,
it's an unprecedented in the history of
their culture.
So it seems also there's a real issue
with human beings when it comes to
patterns of behavior and habits that are
very,
very difficult to break.
And uh,
like as you were saying before,
like if you could have a day where you
could cheat that day,
that would become the habit and then it
would do.
You would be thinking about that one
day.
Like it's very hard for people who are
extremely obese who just their main form
of pleasure is pleasure.
Of course they get that wired it in
their face and then that's what that
whole fucking corndogs so good.
And that's where they're getting their
pleasure from.
It's hard to deviate from that.
It's hard to change your patterns.
Yeah.
You,
you are managing your emotional
wellbeing through the food choices that
you're making,
that you make and they're putting on.
There's a great book called Salt Sugar
Fat by this guy called Michael Morris
and he kind of looks at these big food
companies and draws an analogy to the
tobacco companies in the seventies in
the way that these companies are
funneling money and research and
marketing dollars into devising food
products that are specifically designed
to activate that pleasure center in your
brain.
Right?
So that they know,
they're like,
they're trying to make that food
impossible for you to just have one.
And once you kind of tap into that,
that um,
you know,
ability to trigger that response in
somebody and you create a habit out of
that and addictive response.
Then you have a customer for life,
right?
You know,
it's like,
why is it so hard to eat one fucking
chip?
You know,
there's a reason behind that.
There's something about the,
the,
the proportion of,
of salt and grease,
you know,
that will just trigger something in
somebody.
Do know the feeling that you have when
you do indulge in some really shitty
food that you have just like,
ugh.
After it's over,
you feel like such a loser.
If I like a bag of chips,
go into a shame spiral.
I feel angry at myself.
Fucking dummy ate a bag of chips.
I never went back.
But when you're doing it,
you're like,
I can't even help myself.
It's hard.
Like a greedy,
greedy monster.
Like um,
you know what I read?
I have a,
I have a real weakness for those.
Uh,
salt,
sea salt and vinegar potato chips.
Oh good.
God.
Good.
The real thick one.
The kettle chip.
That's what I'm talking about.
Oh,
they're so good.
And you look at the bag and it says non
GMO in the front.
You're like,
oh,
excellent.
I don't want to GMO potato.
I mean other even gmo potatoes.
I don't know.
I don't say those last a long time.
I think so we'll need to write.
Yeah.
Storm hadn't been heading in that
direction though.
Do potato chips?
That's my guilty pleasure.
It's tough.
The kettle chips are tough.
Fucking real hard Vegan,
you know,
I try not to be bad.
I had a friend is Vegan.
He's fat as fuck.
Well,
it's never been easier.
It's never been easier to be an
unhealthy Vegan.
I mean just walk the aisles at whole
foods or Erewhon like,
you know,
there's so many Vegan ice creams now and
sort of meat alternatives and pasta
sauces that are tasty.
Yeah.
And say getty is totally Vegan and you
get it from the right place.
Oh,
oh yeah.
Without a doubt.
Yeah.
So there's plenty of options now.
And so just because you're Vegan,
that doesn't mean that you're,
you're eating a healthy diet for sure.
You know,
that's important.
I for
people understand.
And there's a lot of people also that
think that drinking juice,
drinking fruit juice is really good for
you.
Be careful about that folks,
because you're not supposed to drink
like a court of orange juice.
That's not how that juice is supposed to
get to your body the way that juice is
supposed to get to your bodies by eating
a fucking orange.
Exactly.
Yeah.
When you drink like a pie quarter of
pineapple juice,
like what?
A fucking shock of sugar to your system
just because it's attached to fruit,
which we,
uh,
assume rightly so is healthy.
Just have some goddamn fruit,
drink some water while you having a big
plate of pineapple and you'll be way
better off than drinking pineapple
juice.
Yeah.
I couldn't agree with you more.
You know,
we're talking about fiber.
It's like,
why would you remove all the fiber?
Yes.
On that plant.
Exactly.
I think juicing has its place though,
but there's a,
there's a huge difference between that
gallon of Tropicana at the grocery store
and cold pressing,
you know,
some Kale and spinach with some tumeric
in it
that's different.
You know what I mean?
Like I think that the sugar.
Yeah,
sugar is the real issue
you can get.
It's,
I look at it as medicinal and you know,
it's like if you want a really
concentrated dose of,
of uh,
you know,
micro nutrients and you know,
the kinds of,
um,
highly compacted vitamins and minerals
that you can get in some of these foods,
these plants than it has its place.
But,
but to,
you know,
run 20 oranges through a juicer and
drink that you're,
you're getting a huge amount of sugar in
that and you're depriving yourself of
the digestive process.
And the fiber that comes with just
eating the whole food,
like nature figured it out,
man.
Like why are you trying to,
you know,
just like the more you focus on eating
these kinds of foods close to their
natural state,
your Palette changes and you start to
desire them.
Like I know these guys that are,
uh,
that are fruitarian like they,
all they eat is fruit like this.
Their whole lifestyle,
right?
It's called the 80 10,
10,
80 10,
10 diet,
80 percent carbs,
10 percent protein,
10 percent fat.
But essentially what it means is they
eat fruit all day long.
That's it totally raw.
They'll eat like 30 bananas a day.
I've heard.
Right?
And so,
so,
you know,
somebody who is from that,
Atkins,
Ketosis,
low carb camp will tell you that that's
an extremely unhealthy thing to do.
Now,
I'm not a fruitarian I don't have any
direct experience with that.
I don't know what the longterm
ramifications of,
of living that lifestyle are.
But I do know people that live this way
and they're super healthy people and
some of them are amazing athletes.
Like my friend Michael Arnstein,
he's fruitarian,
he has been forever,
uh,
and he was like the fifth fastest guide
than New York City Marathon not too many
years ago.
Like,
like an elite athlete who's eating this
way,
that's literally he'll,
he has to eat so much fruit that he has
like two giant extra refrigerators in
his house and he would have to drive
this big truck to like a fruit wholesale
or once a week.
And like the guy at the wholesaler
thought that he had like a bodega or
something like that because he couldn't
believe how much fruit this guy was
buying.
You know,
one of the UFC fighters you'd like that
are there.
I believe Nate Diaz,
he's like that.
I think he's on the 30 bananas a day.
Yeah.
Um,
well,
uh,
but that didn't work.
He got his ass kicked.
I mean,
Mac,
Mac Dansik was playing around with it
for awhile.
I don't know if he's still on it,
but people that I've talked to who have
like dabbled in it say that when they're
doing it they feel amazing and his
people are trim and they don't have.
They're not getting diabetes and
they're,
they're getting a tremendous amount of
glucose.
They're also getting a huge amount of
fiber and they're still meeting their
protein needs.
It's interesting.
So when I look at that,
it just makes me,
it gives me a different perspective on
this obsession that we have with
protein.
Like everyone's walking around worried
about,
you know,
meeting their protein needs.
And the truth is,
is that,
you know,
the average semi sedentary person is
eating two to five times the recommended
daily allowance of protein.
Like it's just,
it's a nonissue.
It's really kind of a red herring.
I should clarify that.
Nate Diaz was probably injured.
I think there was something wrong with
him in his last fight.
So I have nothing to do with his diet.
I'm just fucking around.
And uh,
he also fought Hoffeld dose on Joe's,
which is one of the best fighters in the
world is the current champion.
So his diet,
I'm sure it had nothing to do with him
losing,
but um,
is there a higher dietary requirements
of protein for people that like say
competing power lifting or things along
those lines?
And are there any power lifters that are
Vegan?
There is a guy called Patrick Baboon
Mian.
He's German dude,
German strong man.
This dude is the human wolverine.
He's insane.
And I had that privilege.
I made a youtube video of it.
Maybe you guys can pull it up.
Um,
I was on stage with him at,
uh,
an event in Toronto a couple of years
ago where he attempted to break a
Guinness Book of world record by being,
by carrying more weight than any other
human being ever had.
You put 1200 pounds on a chassis that he
carried.
He had to carry it 10 meters and he
accomplished.
It was extraordinary.
And the guys totally Vegan.
Wow.
Pulled that up.
Did Not Guide the mountain from game of
thrones.
Just break that though.
I think he did like 1600 pounds.
Yeah.
He,
um,
he's like one of the strongest man in
the world.
The guy who was the dude,
he's going to be aquaman.
That guy.
No,
no,
no.
He's.
He's the mountain and the game of
thrones in.
He's from Iceland.
I'm a little bit behind or miss enormous
man.
There was a guy go full screen on the
Kenya or it will fuck us up our videos.
I'll fucking weird here because we do it
all for tri caster.
I to tell you I met one of the guys that
works at Tri caster.
We're hooked up.
Look at this.
Twelve hundred pounds.
Yeah.
Why does it not look at that dark that
doesn't have 1200 DPI?
Definitely is.
There were all these people that are
verifying it and they had all this shit
that doesn't seem like it's 1200 pounds.
Why is that a.
Why does that look so light?
I assure you that it was.
How dare you a day.
That's like 50 pounds.
Is it?
Do you guys get graded on a scale?
Because he's Vegan,
like it's not really 1240 minutes
talking about sounds like dog years
Vegan.
Twelve hundred pounds,
which is 120 pounds.
Well,
he's enormous.
That guy's fucking giant,
so whatever it is,
that guy got all that muscle from being
a Vegan.
Right?
Like a bull.
Ballsy.
Granted he,
he hasn't been a Vegan his entire life,
you know,
so it's not like he was reared that way,
but I think he's been,
he's been that way long enough and he
will tell you that his strength training
improved and his agility and his ability
to recover a was significantly enhanced
when you changed it to the mountain
thousand year old weightlifting record.
He put this huge log on his back.
That guy's enormous.
Terrifying.
Yes.
At different,
a different animal,
especially Iceland.
There's something about Iceland
diversity advice piece on Iceland,
the strong men of Iceland.
The vice did a whole video on it,
like apparently the people in Iceland
did.
They have a long history of being like
strong men competitors for whatever
reason.
It was fucking giant dudes out there
form vikings or something.
Yeah,
it's interesting.
I mean,
I think to your point,
and your question was,
do you think that somebody who's of that
ilk or you know,
like a power lifter or a strength
athlete,
if their.
If their protein requirements are are
higher,
I don't know.
I know that Patrick supplements with
plant based protein powders from time to
time.
I don't know that you know,
he,
he probably is taking in somewhere
between 80 to 100 grams a day.
It's not.
Yeah,
like pre P,
brown rice,
hemp protein,
hemp protein.
I think it's great.
I'm complete amino acid profile.
I mean essentially look,
it's complicated,
right?
It's not,
we can't be reductionist about it,
but in the most general sense when we're
talking about protein,
we're talking about amino acids,
right?
We're talking about the building blocks
of protein and we're specifically
talking about the nine slash amino
acids,
the essential amino acids that we can't
synthesize on around that we have to get
from the foods that we eat.
Right?
So,
so it's a question of making sure that
we are ingesting those nine essential
amino acids.
Right?
So does it matter where they come from?
In what form?
You know,
they,
they are delivered to your body.
Does it matter if it's in hemp or if
it's in steak?
We don't.
No,
we don't.
Yeah,
we don't know.
All I can tell you is that,
you know,
I seem to be doing okay with it,
so,
and I can just share my experience with
it.
That's all.
Yeah.
There's um,
there was an issue,
or Travis Barker was in that plane
crash.
Do you know that story?
Barker,
the drummer?
Yeah,
I,
I've seen the juicy ladies all the time.
He's in the neighborhood.
He,
uh,
he was in a plane crash and had to get
skin grafts and got off of his Vegan
Diet because of that,
like he having a hard time healing and
the starting to me and he healed much
quicker.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I hadn't heard that.
Um,
but that's pretty sure.
He's pretty sure he's,
you know,
he's,
he's pretty hardcore Vegan.
He's partner in that restaurant
crossroads.
Have you been a crossroads?
Where does that phenomenal restaurant
restaurants and it's in Hollywood.
Yeah,
but it's Tal Ronen who's the chef.
There is a mastermind.
He's a genius in the food is
extraordinary.
You should check it out.
Okay.
I'm,
I'm just stating what I heard,
what I read.
I don't know about him after the
accident.
I hadn't heard that.
Is there any properties that would exist
in,
in flesh and blood and eating meat that
would somehow or another benefit you
recovering from an injury?
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
I don't,
uh,
you know,
that,
that would expedite that process.
I mean there are,
there's a difference between the way I
feel when I eat like wild game versus
the way I feel when I eat steak that's
like raised factory rails,
steak or whatever.
There's a difference in the way your
body reacts to it.
Your body has a,
there's a,
there's a feeling that you eat.
Especially Moose.
Moose is very unusual for whatever
reason.
When you eat moose you get this,
like you almost feel like it's a
stimulant.
It's very strange.
Like when you eat rare,
cause heat,
it rare.
It's a very lean and there was this
weird like woo,
like you get a charge after it.
Very similar to what I get when I eat
kale shakes when I,
when I Kale shake some of the things
that I tell people.
If you want to change your diet,
like here's one of the best ways to eat
something healthy,
get a positive reaction from that,
you want to repeat it,
and one of the best positive reactions
I've ever gotten is I drink these Kale
shakes in the morning.
I called them hoke loads,
so I talk about all the time it's Kale,
cucumber,
celery,
a large chunk of ginger,
a four cloves of garlic,
coconut oil,
and an apple blend that sucker up
together and there is a nutrient blast
that you get in there that it's a
tangible,
a stimulant,
sort of a feeling like I get,
I feel stimulant.
Yeah,
that'll get it done.
Right?
And,
and that's what I say to people all the
time.
They're like,
I'm like,
look man,
don't worry about whether you're gonna
do this all the way or what you're going
to do tomorrow.
Just like wake up and drink that salad
for breakfast and make that connection
with how you feel because truly nothing
will make you feel better in the morning
than drinking a super nutrient dense
green shake.
It's just,
you know,
I mean,
whether it has,
you know,
you can have variations on a theme,
like I do something similar,
it's a little bit different and it's
never the same,
you know,
I changed it from day to day or
whatever,
but once you make that connection and
you're like,
Oh wow,
you know,
then that starts to change the microbial
ecology in your gut.
Yeah,
that's interesting,
isn't it?
And the,
and the,
and I think we talked about this last
time too,
like all these studies that are coming
out about how important your microbiome
is to all kinds of things that impact
your health and,
and how and how there's some evidence to
suggest that the quality of your gut
biome,
uh,
can impact your cravings.
Right?
Oh,
for sure.
So sugar,
when you have,
that's a real issue with sugar.
So when people say,
well,
I just crave this,
you know,
my body's telling me that I need it.
Well that's not an objective analysis,
right?
Just because you crave something that
doesn't mean that your body needs it in
my own interview.
Maybe it does,
but if I.
yeah,
exactly right.
So how do you discern between the two?
Yeah,
that's an interesting point.
Um,
would,
that's absolutely a fact when it comes
to a gut microbes when it comes to
sugar,
that if you feed those microbes a lot of
they become dependent upon it and they
need it to survive.
And so they're impulsing you,
I need more of that.
Then you're in this cycle.
So they analyze the gut biome of people
that are like Chocoholics,
right?
And it was very different from people
that are ambivalent about chocolate.
That's such a bizarre thing that you
could have these organisms living inside
your intestinal track that are actually
changing the way you crave things.
So they're sending some sort of stimulus
that gets to your brain and it's
altering the way you,
you,
you want food in your body.
Well,
it's an assault to your idea that you
are essentially human being who is in
control of your thoughts.
And then that leads to the question of
higher consciousness versus you know,
the sort of looping,
you know,
kind of a thing that your brain can do,
right?
Like what does that mean?
You know,
when you observe your own thoughts,
what is it that your who's The observer,
but you know what I mean,
like,
so you know what I mean?
Like if you're having a dream and you're
having a conversation with somebody in a
dream and you're surprised at what
somebody tells you,
but you're imagining that,
right?
Right.
So because you didn't know in your dream
that that person was going to say that
thing to you,
but on some level obviously you did.
Well,
that's the complex nuances of Caruso for
sure.
And,
and the complex nuances of just
consciousness,
you know?
Yeah.
The idea that there could be microbes in
your body that are stimulating and
changing the way your brain functions is
so that,
that seems so alien to people because we
like to think of ourselves as
autonomous.
Right.
But we're not,
we,
we're,
we're far more microbes than human
whamming the percentage.
I don't know.
I can't remember what the percentage is,
but it's ridiculous.
Like,
like the,
the number of,
of microorganisms like trumps the number
of cells you have in your body by like a
factor of,
you know,
some,
I don't know if it's 10 or something
crazy where there's more eco lie living
in your gut than there have ever been
people ever.
That's,
that's real.
Those are real numbers.
There's also,
it's not,
it's not.
You know,
you have to have a healthy symbiotic
relationship with
this,
right?
Like you need it to live.
It's part of being healthy.
Yeah.
We've talked about this,
I believe last time,
various forms of probiotics that you
engage in.
Sauerkraut,
I think you said one of them.
Kimchi,
Kimchi.
I love Kimchi.
Kimchi is great.
Love that stuff.
Come up.
My wife fucking hates it.
Says it makes me smell tough.
Shit.
Yeah.
Kombucha.
I love that stuff too.
But you know,
it pisses me off man.
They fucking.
That a gts Kombucha had to pull the,
the really good stuff and put that water
down horseshit because it's more than
one half of one percent alcohol.
The fermentation process.
Microbes tiny trace of fermentation that
like left a little bit of alcohol in it
that caused this whole thing and they
had to pull it.
They had to pull everything.
We started a state.
We started making our own.
Have you ever made your own gas?
I did it just so you have the big scoby.
I've been in a Kombucha drinker since
94.
When I started drinking it,
I'm Andy Dick turned me onto it and Andy
Dick gave me a fucking,
a slab of Kombucha,
a fungus to take home.
And I got a bowl and I started brewing
it in my refrigerator and a man.
Oh Oj that was long before.
And you know,
gts or anybody.
Oh,
you couldn't buy it.
I used to,
uh,
I used to have a bowl,
like a huge salad bowl in my frigerator
with a fucking living fungus in it.
And I would have the Saran wrap on it.
There was sugar and stuff in the bowl.
I forget what was the ingredients were
and it would feed off of that and I
would leave it in there for a certain
amount of time and then pour it into a
glass and drink it.
It's great,
but it was too much of a pain in the
ass.
And then I'm somewhere in the late
nineties.
I started finding it in stores and then
I got into it.
But now I have a bunch here.
It's everywhere.
I don't,
I don't go.
I mean,
I drink it every day and when I go on
the road,
um,
most of the times I'll find a whole
foods and uh,
I'll stock up on it and leave it in my
hotel room.
I think it's probiotics or.
So I,
I'm very rarely sick.
I mean very rarely and I travel a lot
and one of the things that I attribute
that to is probiotics.
I think that you really,
it's one of the unsung heroes of the
immune system that people don't take
into consideration the symbiotic
relationship that we have with all these
weird microorganisms that you ingest.
And the more of those you have,
the less deficits you have a in terms of
your nutritional intake and the more I'm
more positive microbes and positive bio
organisms that you take into your body,
the more you're going to have the whole
system is going to function better and
be able to fight off immune or fight off
disease better.
Yeah,
for sure.
The example that I always give,
I think I might've shared this last
time,
I'm not sure if we did.
It was the last time was a long time
ago.
Probably nobody saw that anyway,
but,
um,
the example that I always give is,
uh,
is from supersize me,
the Morgan spurlock documentary where he
decides he's going to eat Mcdonald's for
30 days straight.
And for people that saw the movie,
um,
you might remember that,
you know,
a couple of days in,
into this experiment,
you know,
he just,
he can't imagine how he's going to make
it through 30 days.
And there's that scene where he's in the
car and he actually vomited out the
window after he drinks a milkshake or
something like that.
And you just like,
this is the worst.
And then,
and then fast forward like two weeks
later and there's a scene where he's
like waking up in the morning and he's
like,
oh,
I feel so sick.
He's like,
I feel terrible.
let's go to Mcdonald's,
you know,
for his breakfast.
And then he eats,
he eats his whatever he ate for
breakfast at Mcdonald's that morning.
And like,
he walks out and he's like,
I feel awesome.
You know,
like he had to get,
like he had to get his fix.
And so,
you know,
what I see in that is somebody whose
microbiome has adjusted,
he has replaced because at the time his
girlfriend,
uh,
was a Vegan chef,
right?
So he was coming off of eating
essentially a plant based diet.
It goes into this Mcdonald's thing.
And by virtue of bombarding his system
with Mcdonald's food,
uh,
he reap,
he repopulates his gut biome with the
kind of micro organisms that feed off
Mcdonald's food,
right?
So suddenly,
you know,
because those microorganisms are on the
food that you're eating,
right?
And then they feed into your gut and
then they start to propagate and
suddenly he's craving these foods that
were making him sick two weeks earlier
that he couldn't imagine continuing to
eat.
That's the weirdest thing about died is
you're essentially creating a
civilization in your body and the trip.
It really is.
It really.
I mean you're,
you are,
you're,
you're a super organism.
You are a container
and human beings are the microbiome of
the planet,
right?
Yeah.
I mean that's a good sign that our earth
is sick when you check out.
Sure.
An unhealthy gut bacteria for the planet
in a lot of ways.
I mean really is.
It's almost like,
it's almost like everything behaves in
this sort of fractal manner where you
know,
the bigger you get like a main and the
earth itself is probably,
you know,
a microbe in the greater sense of the
galaxy,
which is a micro and a greater sense of
the universe.
And it's all sort of connected in some
weird way.
And that the lower you get down to gut
microbes and how you fuel those gut
microbes and how it impacts the health
of the actual super organism itself.
The human being as a really fascinating.
It really is.
When you stop and think about it,
because very few people think of
themselves as being a host for life.
Like I am just this.
I'm just trying to keep my garden
healthy.
You know the garden of my body,
which is filled.
No,
you think of it.
I am rich roll.
I am this one.
I am the one.
I am one.
I am one thing,
but you're not.
No one is one thing,
but the brain thinks it's one thing
which is a fucker man.
What a weird.
That your brain doesn't realize,
hey,
you know,
I'm,
I'm getting all these signals to eat
Mcdonald's because I've got all these
weird asshole Mcdonald's bacteria living
in my gut and what I need to do,
I need to get some cucumber bacteria
down in there to fuck with the
McDonald's bacteria.
It's a very.
It's a very fascinating thing to be a
human being and to be completely
disconnected from that reality without
externally taking it in,
in the form of education and knowledge
and then having to internalize it,
having to think about and go,
okay,
I need to take into consideration that I
am not just a one,
I am a container for all these different
organisms and the the amount of positive
organisms will directly affect the way
the brain works.
Fuck,
that's hard to think,
man.
That's hard to.
Hard to wrap your head around.
Then factor in the emotional override
that takes over,
that compels you to take an action
irrespective of the logical choice after
you've been educated.
I think that's equally as powerful,
if not more powerful.
Yeah,
all.
Oftentimes that can be adjust.
All that can be adjusted with momentum.
If you can just just fucking force
yourself into a pattern that's more
positive.
Just somehow or another say,
okay.
You know,
like some people say,
I'm going to start training for a
marathon.
I'm going to start on Monday and Monday
I'm gonna run two miles and then you
know,
we're gonna be on the system of recovery
and this is what I'm going to do and
you're going to go into training.
I'm going to start a training camp.
It's all written down and if you can do
that,
if you could do that with your diet,
I can't tell you how many people have
come up to me and said I have lost a
tremendous amount of weight since listen
to your podcasts because I started
incorporating Kale shakes into my diet.
That's my primary breakfast is a Kale
shake and it changed everything.
I mean I'm talking about hundreds.
It's almost like a joke.
Like I run into people and go,
dude,
I lost 100 pounds from your pocket.
Okay.
Another guy.
It's almost like a job.
Like,
I mean you tweeted out that I was coming
on the podcast and there's like 50
comments after that about hulk loads all
about the hulk load.
Well,
I added beats to the whole clothes
because of you.
You recommended.
Yeah.
Beats will get you out of bed in the
morning.
He eats are fantastic.
That's the ultimate like preworkout
boost.
What a nutrient rich plant that is a
root does.
They're amazing.
Just like the first time you do it
though,
don't freak out the first time you take
a dump.
All bloody red beets.
Yeah,
I know.
It's crazy.
It's actually done.
You go to the store and you get,
you get the beats right and you put them
on the thing and like unless you say
otherwise they are going to cut the,
the beet Greens off and throw them away.
That's the good stuff,
man.
That's also good as well.
Well yeah,
it's definitely good as well.
I mean I don't know why people don't
think that's edible.
Isn't that strange?
So we just have this idea that we were
very rigid and like our idea,
like what you eat,
what you don't eat like that,
just throw that out,
chop that off.
A beet.
Greens are awesome and they don't taste
bad.
It's not like it's a,
it's weird.
You don't,
you never see a beat green salad.
That's not,
that's not common to at our house.
Joe Rogan.
Whoa.
Richard called me out.
Um,
what are,
what are some other like,
here's a funny thing on.
I fucking saw the other data foods.
Bok Choy is the new Kale,
Bok Choy.
You Fox.
That's good too.
It's not just the new Kale.
What is that?
Why do people have to do that?
One of their ruined everything when
they're nonsense.
Just orange and black.
We live in a commercial,
you know,
we live in a commercial society right
there.
They got to push something else out
I don't know,
you know,
it's the same thing that,
there's a white bus fleet.
Buzzfeed is always,
you know,
there's crazy headlines about crazy
stuff that's inflammatory and whatever.
Click bait like.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Do you grow your own vegetables?
That's our next thing that we're looking
into and we have a bunch of land so I as
underutilized and,
and so we just started meeting with a
bunch of people to start.
Start growing.
Yeah,
it,
we've been doing that for awhile now at
my house and it's was very rewarding to
have like a,
we had a cucumber salad the other day,
cucumber,
tomato salad.
It was so good.
It was like this.
I saw this when it was a fucking seed in
a little container and put it in the
dirt.
And um,
what do you use for to.
Oh,
you don't grow so you don't have like A.
Yeah,
we're,
I mean,
you know,
we'll,
we'll get into that once we start
growing,
but the one thing that we are doing,
which is fucking awesome is a,
we started,
um,
we have,
we have all these uh,
beehives now we have like 30 hives that
our house that we're hosting for a
friend who is like an organic beekeeper
who creates his own honey.
And that's been super interesting also
for the kids to like learn about,
you know,
what that's all about.
I mean that is so interesting.
That's cool.
Works,
which is really cool.
I want to do that.
And I also,
I was thinking about doing that.
I was like,
God,
it's a lot of work and bringing the
fucking beehive guy and all,
but I found out about this new
invention.
Yeah.
This guy that Australia is created,
you've seen it all the tap.
It's the.
Yeah.
He had like the craziest kickstarter of
all time.
He raised like insane millions of
dollars.
He was only trying to raise 100 grand or
200 grand or something and you've raised
$4 million dollars in like no time
because it's in his invention is so
astounding.
Well,
I was definitely a part of that because
when I got it,
it wasn't nearly that much.
I,
I've,
I tweeted the shit out of that.
I thought it was amazing.
It's a,
you take have.
You actually probably had a lot to do
with him raising all a little bit of
something interesting.
I'm sure a lot of people reacted the way
I will look.
The 100 percent of what had to do with
it was this invention is amazing.
Twelve dollars million.
Holy Shit Dude.
When I looked at it,
I swear to God,
I don't think it was more than a couple
hundred thousand dollars.
I mean,
I think I looked,
I looked at it maybe a couple of weeks
ago and I think it was like at four,
which is a lot.
That's amazing,
but it just shows how cool it is a good
idea,
you know,
play it because it's really amazing.
If anybody hasn't heard,
well,
you know the people that are listening,
you're,
you're only going to hear it,
but this guy invented a beehive that
essentially has a.
there's a dial that you can turn and the
dial changes the honeycombs into a flow
pattern.
It actually opens up and then the honey
drips down slowly into these jars.
It doesn't disturb the BS.
It doesn't disturb any of the normal
natural processes that these bees engage
in to make honey and it's so much less
invasive and when you see it,
if you go to the video,
it's called flow hive.
If you go to the video online and
they'll do a much better job of
explaining how all this is made,
but it's a.
it's really fucking cool,
right?
Indiegogo,
indiegogo campaign,
but you don't get the bee pollen and uh,
you don't get the,
uh,
the actual honeycomb itself,
which I like to eat.
I love that stuff.
Yeah.
I mean,
the idea is that you're not disturbing
the bees,
right?
You're not really invading their,
you're not impeding on their kind of
habitat.
Was that funny Vegan now because honey
wasn't Vegan for a long
time.
I mean,
look,
there are,
there is a hardcore Vegan perspective
that,
that honey,
you know,
you shouldn't eat honey animal product,
um,
but it's not.
And I respect people that have that
opinion.
I mean,
I think that,
you know,
my perspective on it is,
is that,
you know,
our bee populations are threatened and
because of,
you know,
he has to be in fucking idiots and you
know,
we've,
we've fucked a lot of shit up,
right?
Phones too.
Right?
And so I think that,
that,
you know,
our family is trying to be of service by
helping foster,
you know,
co the cultivation of bee populations
and uh,
you know,
in a sustainable way like by being,
by getting involved,
you know,
there's one,
there's one school of thought like we'll
leave it alone,
right.
But this is a,
this is a threatened,
you know,
population that needs a little bit of
know,
graceful intervention were to help help
them foster their population.
So to the extent that I can play a small
part in that,
I think that's a cool thing.
No,
I think that's a cool thing as well.
And I,
and I agree,
there's,
there's that,
the very hardcore a segment of the Vegan
population that don't think that you
should eat honey,
but they don't have it like this,
you know,
this is like,
normally when you get honey,
it's like this really complicated
process.
You have to pull the,
the hives out and you have to scrape the
honey off and extract it in that way.
This is,
it's totally different.
It's a different animal than commercial
honey production.
You,
there's
practices involved with that that are
harmful to those insects,
right?
So to the extent that you can find a
better way to do it,
um,
where you're still able to harvest the
honey in a way that,
that is not,
you know,
kind of overly tapping into what they
need to survive and thrive.
Um,
I don't know.
It's also,
again,
this is like,
you know,
it gets into like splitting hairs.
It's like,
all right,
we're going to talk about this when we
have,
you know,
when,
55 percent of co two emissions is caused
by animal agriculture.
We have bigger fish to fry,
bigger things like,
so,
you know,
I'm just trying to kind of,
help bee populations in,
in,
in our tiny little way by educating my
kids about it.
And by being a home to these 40 hives,
which is a trip.
It's a lot of hives,
40 hives,
you have eli,
how there's this.
They're like,
I think they stack them for high.
So there's 10 of those 10 bottles.
Towers.
Yeah,
down the hill,
I dunno,
three or four feet high.
Um,
and it was,
they brought them in the middle of the
night and it was like,
okay,
like are we going to have swarming be,
you know,
as they're going to be like we were
like,
don't go near them for a couple days,
like let them acclimate,
you know,
they have to get used to like their
environment and what sorts of.
I mean,
the way that bee populations function is
a trip
is really trippy.
The little aliens.
Do you have to plan specific flowers
around your area to help them?
We haven't had,
did you that?
I mean the big kind of hurdle that we
had to get over was making sure that we
had adequate water supply for them.
But I'm not that I'm aware of.
We have in our,
on our property we have specific plants
and flowers that attract bees and the
other ones that attract hummingbirds.
We have a lot of hummingbirds on our
property just because of that because we
put certain,
certain plants and flowers.
But the bees have a real issue
apparently with cell phones.
Um,
I was reading this whole thing about how
the towers like impact them some,
the actual signals themselves,
they,
they impact the bees' ability to
communicate.
They fuck with their head.
They can hear that shit.
It wouldn't surprise me and the way that
they have the high,
they literally have the hive mind and
the way that they,
they sort of functioned in that way.
Like the,
you know,
the frequency at which they're
communicating is so mysterious and
amazing.
Yeah.
So it's so cool.
I've told this story before,
but you might not have heard it.
When we were on fear factor,
one of the stunts they had these people,
they're the data get handcuffed to a
pole or something like that.
And then we covered them with bs and
while we're doing this,
the beekeeper told us that we had to
stop filming because a local population
of bees had came over to investigate his
population of bees and they were above
us in this cloud,
in the air,
sorting it out.
They weren't fighting.
They were somehow or another
communicating like,
who the fuck are you guys?
Oh man,
we're here for a TV show.
Okay,
so you're not moving in?
No,
we're not moving in.
Are you guys
taking our pollen?
No,
we're not taking your pile.
Like and they had an,
they worked it out.
They worked it out and then they
disappeared and then we kept filming but
it took,
we had an amazing.
It was really cool.
It was really cool to watch because it
was like what is going on and not,
you know,
and I mean everybody was,
it was weird how people were interested
in it because Oh we got to stop filming
apparently like those local bee
populations intermix with this be
published.
And I was like,
what?
First of all I was high as fuck.
So it was super,
super interesting to me.
So I was like,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
When they're talking like how do you
know whose Beezer,
who's bs?
He goes and he was like,
you could tell just by the way there
they're swarming in the air or they're
trying to work this out.
And so there was this small cloud of
these bees because he had brought a lot
of bees and the local bees got together
with his bees and they were hovering,
but they had to disperse like they told
everyone to get away.
They told the crew to get away.
Everyone leave the area,
you know,
he wanted to make sure that there was
nothing fucking with this interaction.
This strange because he has.
You have like the BBC.
Yeah,
he will.
He's a deep respect for bees.
This guy really does love bees was
really,
really interesting.
It was interesting for me too because I
was covered with bees and that episode.
I mean they were all over my hair,
my face and my arms and everything like
that and I never got stung.
Gets done.
A couple people got stung on the set,
but I don't know what happened.
It could have been like,
you know,
like maybe if like a bs in your armpit
and you,
you,
you move your arm and it gets trapped
and it's like fuck this and it stings
you.
Probably just just accidental
circumstances that came from having
millions or thousands or whatever it
was.
Right,
right.
That's pretty interesting.
Yeah,
it was really cool.
It was really cool seeing them all get
together and try to figure it out and
just flying overhead.
Just communicating in some way that we
just really don't even have a clue.
We believe pheromones are involved,
but we also know that there's some sort
of signal that they're sending out and
we just don't know what it is.
You know?
This whole insect world is a real trip.
I mean they really are alien.
They really are some strange alien life
form.
We found them on another planet.
We will be blown away.
Yeah.
I mean just the idea that there's a
queen and,
and,
and the fact that the hive is lost
without it.
Yeah.
And that everything kind of falls into
place when the,
when the queen is inserted into the
population.
I mean,
I can't begin to,
you know,
like I know very little about this.
How about the Queens?
A murderous bitch.
She's got a fucking Stinger that doesn't
come off.
It doesn't,
she doesn't have like barbs on it the
way everyone else does and what she does
is she wanders around the hive looking
for female babies and she stabs him
right through the honeycomb.
Yeah,
that's what the female users.
Oh,
it's awful.
She's fucking heartless cunt.
And one day she will be usurped.
There were a new female will come along
and kick her ass and that's it.
But right now
she's going to stab those babies.
So she runs around like sticking her
needle and the honeycomb when she smells
a female fucking girl in there and take
my spot.
No threat to the throne.
Yeah.
It's very bizarre.
World of bugs.
Have you ever seen the leaf cutter ant a
documentary?
They did where they,
they cemented,
they poured cement through this leaf
cutter ant hive,
this enormous hill.
And then they dug it out and structure.
It was incredibly labyrinthine right?
And it went,
it was vast.
It was huge,
huge and incredibly complex.
Like they had areas where these leaves
would ferment and then they had pipes
that led tubes that lead through to the
sky or to the,
uh,
the surface area where they would hit
air so that they could the fermentation
process,
the gases can be released.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
Like with these tiny brains figure out
like we don't even know like,
well,
human beings would fuck that up and it
makes sense for sure.
Unions will get involved.
And there it is again.
Look at that.
Oh right.
Yeah,
I did.
I did see this industry in the rain
forest.
Right.
It's like they did an archeological dig
to like extract it,
right?
Yeah.
They filled it up with cement and I
mean,
first of all,
it's an enormous.
When you look at how wide it is,
it's probably 50 feet wide and it's
insane.
It's very deep as well.
And there's so much to it.
There's so much going on there.
And how are they communicating with who
was the architect of all this structure?
How did they figure this out?
We all know how to do this.
Like what in the fuck man.
Unbelievable.
And a huge fucking mystery.
And until a decade or two ago we had no
idea what the fuck was even below the
surface.
We had no idea what they were doing down
there.
I mean it really is amazing.
It is just absolutely amazing.
Have you seen the ant death spiral?
Have you ever seen that now?
Well that's a trip.
It like king of the obscure animal
video.
So I do remember it.
Spring free time.
And I love to watch a animal nature
videos cause I think it's very under
appreciated.
The,
the uniqueness or the just the,
just the eccentricities of the animal
world.
Just how amazing and fascinating.
What is that it is that crazy?
A rodent that looks like a few bar.
Yeah.
Did you see that one where they're
climbing into a hot tub?
Like this hot tub party?
There's an animal.
There's an amazing.
Alright,
this is an ant carol.
And this is when the queen dies.
When the queen dies and the scent is no
longer there.
They don't know who to follow,
don't know what the fuck to do.
And they go into this spiral and they
will just do this until they run out of
energy and food and they will fucking
die is probably literally shitty job.
They'll just continue to spend like that
until they just parish.
Yeah.
They don't know where to go.
They don't know who to follow.
I mean there's a,
there's a hierarchy in the ant
community.
Uh,
I'm sure it could be explained cve,
find an explanation for Jamie.
I probably butchered it,
but the,
the idea being that they're following
the scent of the Queen and somehow or
another lose it.
And so they don't know what to do.
So they just start going into the
spiral.
Maybe someone stepped on the queen or
something happened.
They removed the queen perhaps.
And a bird might've stolen the queen
like a dragon come down,
swoop and take away their queen.
Now.
World's crazy mysterious place.
Well,
insects in particular,
could we,
we,
we know we don't think of him that much
because they're so small,
but ants have the almost exact same
calculated biomass as human beings when
it comes to weight,
meaning that there is exactly the same
amount of ant weight per the bodies of
ants on earth is there are humans.
Oh,
you mean in total total.
Like if you added up all the ants and
all the humans,
that the,
the total mass would be the equal.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
That's so many answer are how many
fucking answers it take to equal 180
pound person.
It's got to be a lot.
What's the average height or weight of a
person?
It's probably somewhere around there,
like one 60 or something like that.
You know,
between men and women.
Not In the US.
Yeah,
it's like a hundred pounds more than
that,
right?
The average.
It was a how to make ants commit
suicide.
We go into a spiral.
You can make them do it.
Why would you do that?
Dick?
Simply divert the ants into an enclosed
space such as a plant pot,
large discovers a staggering 1000,
200 feet in diameter with each ant
completing a circuit every two and a
half hours.
Holy Shit.
Whoa.
So you can make them do it that I'm able
to break free owing to their lack of
sight and they march around in a loop
until they dropped dead.
What does it say before that explains
it?
How do they remove the army?
Has Navigate by following the pheromone
trails left behind by others.
However,
should enough of them lose the scent,
they begin to follow the aunt
immediately in front of them and a huge
ant spiral forums.
Ah,
it.
Follow the scent of those in front of
them.
Lots of fucking trip.
And how weird.
It was weird that not only did nature
somehow or another have a need for this,
but it,
you know,
it came about,
it developed and it's been the same way
that way for who knows how many of
years.
What is the evolutionary purpose of that
though?
Just they follow each other.
They can't see shit,
but who the fuck is the first guy who?
What does he know?
How does he know what he's doing?
Should go and deep joe believes in
making these from fermentation bowls and
the ground and like,
wow,
trippy fucking world.
The insect world is the insect world to
me is one of the most bizarre world or
the most overlooked because they're so
small.
We don't think of him as as alien as
they truly are.
You know,
if an ant was the size of a dog,
it would be the fuck.
I mean,
it's downright prehistoric.
Oh,
beyond?
Yeah.
I mean they're,
they're prehistoric.
Even to dinosaurs.
Dinosaurs.
Look at answering.
What the fuck is that crazy thing with
an exoskeleton with unbelievable
physical strength.
Physical strength than an man has.
The power to weight ratio is pretty off
the charts.
Oh,
it's incredible.
Incredible.
I'm you ever seen ants carry large
things away,
which is what the fuck,
man.
Now the world is a ruthless,
evil vicious world to ever see when the
female ants get ahold of vyvanse leaf
cutters as well,
to get a hold of a male.
Males are larger and they have wings,
might be not be leaf cutters,
but whatever it is,
they chopped the wings off of the male,
chop his arms and legs and then carry
him to the,
to the hive to breed.
I haven't seen that bitches so rude.
I had to bone up on my nature videos,
I think.
Yeah,
I probably have to bone down.
You probably have too many of them in
there.
Too much useless information.
You have the time,
Joe.
I don't know.
I don't know where it comes from.
I just,
I get compelled to research things and
to follow up and to start reading and
watching things.
And then next thing you know them have
gone on this crazy cycle.
Is that a?
Yeah.
What kind of answered is the biggest
answer?
Two and a half inches.
Oh,
that's a big ass aunt.
Well,
if you ever seen with wings,
my friend Brian Cowen at one point in
time was studying to be a scientist and
uh,
he would,
he had spent some time in a rain forest,
I think it was Borneo,
a new New Guinea and forget what it was,
but they had to.
Everyone stayed in these tents and he's
elevated platforms.
They had a coat.
The posts with Turpentine.
Yeah,
because there were so many ants and if
the army ants found you,
if they found you in one of them decided
to bite you just like they follow the,
sent millions and millions and millions
and they would just eat you alive.
And people would regularly get killed by
ants there.
That's crazy.
How about the fact they kill elephants?
They climb up the elephant's leg,
they find the ear and they start eating
the fucking elephant's brain and then
they all fall ascent and they all
follow.
Go up the elephant body and eat his
fucking brain alive from the inside and
kill a lot of things you wouldn't think.
Well,
it,
it's all you have to do is leave like
something out on your kitchen counter
for five minutes and out of mysterious
nowhere.
A line of ants will appear and then,
and then if you remove it,
they disappear.
Well,
have you ever seen something outside
that wasn't there before and then all of
a sudden the flies find it and then
within minutes there's all these fucking
flies.
There was no flies and then within
minutes they find this and somehow in or
they go,
Yo,
here we go,
we've got something.
And then there's all these fucking
flies.
It's very like,
how do they do in that?
We don't even know.
We have no idea.
I don't know.
We got diverted.
You need.
I know you need a insect ologist.
Is that what they would be called?
Come on,
sort of a word for that.
What does it show?
Entomologist emojis.
That's right.
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
What's the study of words?
The origins of words at technology.
Etymology.
Don't get confused.
They'll order one and get the other.
I'm trying to find out the origin of the
word cunt.
Well,
I didn't know about bugs.
I don't know what you're trying to.
A lot of layers to that.
Brian Callahan.
What compelled him to want to study
that?
I don't know.
There's a lot of layers to Brian.
Brian's a deep dude.
You know,
you start getting to know him.
You dig deeper and deeper and deeper.
You find those educational background
and he's a.
He knows a lot of shit about weird
stuff,
you know?
Yeah.
But that,
that freaked him out.
He said he could hear the marching ants.
You hear them more?
Yeah.
That's crazy.
So many of them on the floor that you
just,
you realize like,
oh my God is millions of them.
You were talking about how you're a huge
radio lab fan,
right?
Yes.
Have you,
have you gotten down with this show,
invisibilia?
No.
It was pretty cool,
man.
I think he would dig it.
Is that a difference in other different
podcasts?
It's another one of those invasive
invisibilia.
It's another kind of NPR offshoot,
you know,
like how sort of IRA glass at this
American life.
All these producers that have worked for
him have now started all these other
podcasts.
I'm super interesting stories.
There was one recently about a guy who I
guess is a pretty well known guy.
Um,
he's blind.
I think he went blind as far as it like
a four year old or something like that.
He lost his sight and he started in
school.
He started making these like clicking
noises with his mouth like,
like that.
And his teachers would say,
you know,
what are you doing?
Settle Down,
stop doing that.
And his mother realized very early on
that there was some purpose to this.
There was some reason why he was doing
this show location.
Yeah.
And,
and what they realized is that he was
developing over many years of practicing
this,
like a finely attuned sonar ability.
Like he would literally be able to,
uh,
figure out like where he was and what
was in a room and what was going on.
Basically making these clicking noises
in the,
in the sound waves bouncing off.
And he developed this acuity to be able
to discern from that the parameters of
his environment to the extent that he,
he like goes running.
He like rides a bike.
It's insane.
Like what this guy has been able to do
as a blind person.
He goes running and his whole thing is.
His whole thing is that he doesn't think
that he's anything special.
He thinks that all blind people could
develop this skill,
but that our education around blindness
is sort of,
um,
a,
a vernacular of disability,
right?
We're where we say,
well,
you're disabled.
You can't do this and we're going to put
you into this system and this is how we
do it with blind people.
And he's like,
that's bullshit.
Like everybody could learn to do what
I'm doing.
We need to like empower blind people in
this way.
It's super interesting.
It was like a long interview with this
guy.
But anyway,
each week they have some kind of
interesting story like that.
Well,
there was a video of a young kid who can
do that.
A young kid who walks on the street
makes a clicking noises and he knows
we're trash cans are and stuff.
That's crazy,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
so,
so like the,
the latent abilities that we all have,
right?
If we develop them,
it's sort of like how the disability
unlocks some other aspect of your brain
that that needs to develop in order to
survive.
One of the best pool players in the
world is a young man named Shane van
Boning and he's deaf.
It's been deaf since birth.
And when he plays,
he shuts his hearing aid off and it
allows some trademark look at this.
Oh,
that's the guy that Sam is a different
guy than the other guy was a young black
guy.
Right?
So this is the guy from the,
from that podcast.
So is he doing okay?
Kish?
Completely blind.
In fact,
he doesn't even have eyes say for
prosthetic ones.
Daniel has never seen a tree,
a car,
or even the bicycle he's writing.
So how does he know where he's going?
He's literally driving on the street
traffic.
The answer can be found in the clicking
sound.
You hear it's called Echo location.
Bats use it to fly around in the dark
and dolphins use it to navigate the
oceans.
Daniel uses echolocation or sound to see
every environment has its own acoustical
signature.
Every surface has its own acoustical
Daniel was born with an aggressive form
of cancer called retinoblastoma.
By the time he was 13 months old,
both of his eyes were removed.
Your 45,
so you lost your sight at such a young
age.
You don't have any,
any memory of vision?
I have no memories at all.
I was using echolocation from the age of
two or younger,
but I really didn't know that much about
it.
It was just how you.
How you adapted to your environment
without really understanding it.
Yes.
I doubt very seriously that most sighted
people give much thought or attention
about how they see,
so I really didn't give thought or
attention about how I see Daniel uses
echolocation to right
bike
cook.
Is this a dish that you normally cook
Daniel,
or are you experimenting with me?
Even hike alone in the mountains using
sound to see can be a hard concept for a
sighted person to understand what the
father,
Daniel,
will tell you.
He sees his environment as a series of
images created in his mind based on what
he hears using echolocation,
so you're calling out into the
environment,
you're essentially asking the
what are you and where are you,
and you're receiving those answers so
you're getting an image in your mind.
Yes,
I definitely get a three dimensional
images with depth and character and
richness and I can process those and I
can interact with those from his modest
bungalow in long beach.
Daniel runs a small nonprofit called
world access for the blind.
Since being established in 2000 world
access has been the lone voice preaching
echolocation.
In fact,
every major blind organization in
America does not support Daniel's
mission.
So Daniel,
the national federation of the blind,
will say that echo location is just too
complicated for for most blind people to
grasp.
It's not so much the federation that's
that's a concern you have here,
a blinded ms dot profession.
The blindness field who by and large
really kind of interactively remains
committed,
if you will,
to a traditional approach,
which is about,
in my opinion,
restriction.
It is about this is how you do things,
this is the right way for a blind person
to do things.
This is safe,
this isn't safe.
Watching that guy drive his bike is a
fucking trip.
That is bizarre.
Right?
And so you watch that and it makes you
just think about human capability in a
different way.
Well,
it certainly does.
It certainly makes you wonder like what?
What else we could do,
you know,
if we could figure that out,
if,
if there's a person like him that can
figure out how to see things with his
sound were making echo locations.
Like what,
what other,
what other possible senses could be
developed?
And to that extent,
you know,
well in the animal kingdom there's like
art,
they training these German shepherds
that can smell cancer like early onset
of cancer.
They're doing similar things with rats
and you know,
I mean obviously those animals have a
more developed sense in that area,
but to the extent that human beings have
unlocked potential in areas that we
haven't really looked at,
I think it's pretty interesting.
Well,
people certainly have finally developed
senses like certain people that play
instruments have finally developed
senses of sound.
Somalis have finally developed sense of
tastes like he ever talked to someone
who's like a real wind,
Somalia and they can,
they can drink a glass of wine,
have a sip of it and tell you what part
of the world he came from.
Like that's real.
That means they can sip it and tell you
what part of France there they're
growing these fucking grapes there.
These people with crazy noses that work
in the perfume industry that are highly
paid to,
you know,
decipher these accents.
It's like something I couldn't even
relate to,
but I think in general,
you know,
a need is the mother of that invention.
Like somebody who's not in Daniel's
condition is not on their own going to
develop echolocation.
Right.
You know what I mean?
It also makes you really wonder if there
are fields,
like we were talking about how bees can
tune into the sound that a cell phone
makes and it fucks with them.
I wonder if there's anything like that
that's effecting us and social sort of a
strange way that we're not aware of
because one of the things that I'm
always like really aware of when I go,
if I go to the wilderness,
if I go to a real wild place is this
sound of it is different than the sound
of silence here.
Like if you're in a park here and it's
beautiful,
it's nature's,
it's nice,
it's relaxing,
but there's a certain tone to like
Prince of Wales Island in Alaska is a
perfect example.
We were there and we were on top of this
mountain.
We're sitting there.
I was like,
you hear that.
Like it's like,
it sounds different.
It feels different here.
It's like you're getting a signal of no
signal.
There's no cell phone,
there's no radio.
You're not tuning into anything other
than nature itself and it has a
different tone to it than a city has.
Well for sure.
I mean,
I would say that there's,
you're saying there's no signal,
but I think there's probably a really
powerful signal.
It's just a different signal goes the
wrong way to say it.
Yeah.
You know,
listen,
everything is vibration and energy and
if you don't think that,
that,
uh,
that isn't real,
you know,
go hang out with negative people for a
week and see how you start behaving.
So trying to,
you know,
an environment is no different and we
tend to believe that if we can't see
something that it's not real.
So here's,
you know,
Daniel,
who you know is putting out sound waves
into the world and he's able to figure
out what his environment is.
You can't see that.
He can't see that.
But to him it's very real and you know,
we're surrounded by all kinds of crazy
invisible energies in waves from cell
towers to
Wifi signals and all this kind of stuff.
I mean,
do we know how this is impacting us?
I know people that are super sensitive
to,
uh,
to Wifi and cell phones,
like they get headaches and all kinds of
things.
So what is this Jamie?
Students Science experiment finds plants
won't grow near Wifi router.
Some ninth graders in Denmark did a test
where they put what they said was,
are they tested a.
it's the same radiation of cell phone
gives off.
So they put some watercress I think is
what it's called,
or garden crest and six trays in one
room,
six trays and another with two wifi
routers and essentially as you can send
a picture,
didn't grow.
The ones in the Wifi routers is no
different in the environment other than
the fact that Wifi routers were there.
Yeah,
that ain't good.
That's frightening.
It is.
Twelve days of growth and then it
totally makes sense.
I mean there's a signal if your phone
can pick up that signal,
there is something in the air and that
something in the air is probably
disruptive to other things that are also
in the air.
Yeah.
That's fucking up the BS.
What's it doing to your brain?
Exactly right.
It feels different man.
When you go to a place with no cell
phone signal,
it literally feels different and it's so
rare that we do that.
So rare,
yeah,
but it's not just,
it's not just the cell phone signal.
I mean it's all kinds of things.
People give off a certain signal to.
People want to think that that's hippy
and woo woo,
but man,
when you're around really negative
people that are going to go away from
this person and it's not just,
you got to get away from them because
they say certain things like they give
off a vibe,
you know,
that that's like,
that's a hippie thing to say the vibes
guys giving me a bad vibe man.
But I think it's real.
I think there are certain rules.
You walk into a room and you're like,
well,
there's a heavy energy and you know,
there's something weird.
It doesn't feel right to me.
You know?
I got,
you get,
you get like anxious and you got to
leave.
Yeah,
right.
Everybody's had that experience.
Well that's why nobody wants to buy a
house where someone was killed in it.
The house is awesome.
You find out that there was like a
double homicide there.
You're like,
fuck this place.
Have you ever been up in,
uh,
towards Simi?
Um,
that like dry lake bed in Chatsworth?
Yes.
What's that Canyon called?
Right there.
That's creepy.
I'm Tapo.
No,
no,
no.
I Dunno.
You know what I'm talking.
I,
you're talking about though,
like I've written my,
I ride my bike all,
you know,
I could do a lot of training around here
and I've written up that canyon.
It's a great client,
but like there's something weird,
you know,
you can feel like a weird energy and it
turns out that box,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Box Canyon.
Yeah.
And like,
um,
what's that chance and family?
Um,
yeah,
there was like the mansons were back
there and also there are,
I think it's Boeing is back there.
Yes.
Contractors where they were doing
nuclear testing in the ground,
which is why that's a dry lake bed and
there's still people that
will tell you that they're,
you know,
it's not so safe there.
They,
they,
they did some shit out there,
you know.
Well they definitely did some shit
there.
And not only that,
there was some in,
in seeing me,
there were some water well tasks that
they did that found traces of rocket
fuel in the water.
Well,
and there's a cleanup that's going on up
there right now is a really susanna
pass.
People are worried about that clean up
because they're worried about is that if
they start digging and cleaning up that
the dust is going to get into the air
and it's going to blow through the
valley and whatever trace elements of
that rocket fuel.
Apparently there was a lot of disasters
up there.
They did a lot of shit down there in the
fifties and the sixties.
Early testing on stuff.
Yeah.
They had like some sort of a nuclear
thing there as well.
Apparently there was a nuclear incidents
much worse than three miles worse than
three mile island.
Really?
In 1959 they had something worse than
through my own.
Huh?
La Apparent.
I read a study on it though and one of
the things that said the study like the
half life of the type of radiation that
they have is very short lived.
So it's not something that lingers in an
area.
The real concern that the apparently
according to what I read,
that the sober environmentalist are
concerned with is the rocket fuel that's
leaked into the ground and gotten into
the well water in that area.
That's the real concern.
Is that.
Is that why the lake that is dry?
I don't know.
I've no idea whether they pose try.
Interesting.
I,
I knew a dude who lived near a golf
course and the pesticides from the golf
course leaked into the well and he got
cancer.
His neighbor guard cancer kids in his
neighborhood.
It was like all throughout the
neighborhood,
people got cancer,
they got cancer because of the
pesticides.
Like they all got a very specific type
of bone cancer.
Scary Shit.
Like he doesn't have a femur.
One of his femurs is like a metal rod
that they replaced his femur with
because he had cancer.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
And it's from pesticides.
There was a big class action.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know what,
what the fuck went down,
but you know,
bone cancer from a golf course.
Fuck,
you know.
Imagine what our rocket facility they're
dumping,
what kind of Shit they're dumping into
that fucking ground.
Kidding,
right.
I mean,
you know,
our world is getting more and more
toxic,
right?
All these things we have to worry about.
Think about,
think about,
you know,
look on the back of,
the average package food that you pick
up at the grocery store and all the
ingredients in it and like,
you know,
who knows what all that stuff is,
whether it's safe and we're interesting
regulatory bodies to make these
decisions for us.
Right.
How about meditation?
Yeah,
of course.
Right.
Hold on.
New Medications are constantly coming
out.
Side effects.
I mean the commercials are just comedic,
you know,
like literally way more disclosures
about side effects than actual product
information.
Yeah.
We played one for acne medicine the
other day.
That was hilarious.
Well,
because there was this like suicidal,
not just suicide.
They were talking about bloody diarrhea.
They had these really pretty girls and
they were walking down the street.
There were bopping.
One of the girls in that commercial,
the redheaded girl contacted me on
twitter.
They had no idea what the fuck they were
selling,
you know,
they're just trying to be pretty,
they don't,
they're not talking in the commercial,
right,
but they're bopping down the street to
that forelle song happy and uh,
they have like beautiful skin and
beautiful hair and they're perfect bone
structure and they literally like
bopping as they're walking,
like they're in some happy music video.
And then as they're doing that,
the,
the start reading the laundry list of
possible potential side effects that are
fatal bloody diarrhea,
stomach cramps,
all these different things.
And they're very specific which could be
fatal just because you're getting zits.
And again,
like you're saying like you're looking
back on the couch watching this.
I mean we've signed up for this.
I mean the Orwellian dystopia and he's
like weirder than you could've ever
imagined.
Right.
And again,
what you were talking about earlier is
you're using a medication to deal with
an issue that if you take a holistic
approach,
what's causing you to have acne,
right?
What is causing your skin to break out
and some sort of a horrible way that you
need this fucking bloody diarrhea
inducing medication to combat it?
Yeah.
I mean at some point you know the side
effects far outweigh the condition that
you're trying to treat and they're too
bloody diarrhea.
There's.
There isn't even a single thought put
into the cars.
Like why don't we talk about what might
be leading to this and maybe some
choices that you could make that could
alleviate or prevent this.
No,
just take this.
Well,
you can't make any money with those
choices.
Joy,
you're bloody diarrhea.
There's only one way to make the money
was the way to make the money is you
gotta you gotta sell the stuff.
You don't.
You don't make money by getting people
and you can.
You can write a book book,
make some money.
It's not going to make us money.
Money is accutane or some point.
Know that Broccoli growers need to
unite.
Yeah.
Imagine if there was like a plant that
cured zits is one plant.
Boy,
would they make that plan illegal?
Quick crutching on all the advisors.
Profits are so,
yeah,
all that.
What is that stuff?
The benzoyl peroxide,
the stuff is all that money.
Oh yeah.
All that does is to see 10 dries your
skin out.
So it does.
It's all a puskus gets dried out and
your skin feels like shit.
Yeah,
I mean look,
you know,
western medicine is fantastic if you
have an acute disorder.
I'm not like,
you know,
against Western medicine or
pharmaceuticals when appropriate.
I just think that that,
you know,
we're too quick to take them to deal
with things that might be better
addressed in other ways.
I agree.
And it's also as.
Why's it have to be one of the other
wise,
it has to be pharmaceutical drugs are
evil or they're great.
No,
it's like sometimes
they're great and sometimes they're evil
and you know,
the problem is profit.
Once profit gets in the way,
our profit gets into the mix.
That'd becomes a soul thing you're
chasing.
It's not like let's make sure that what
we're doing is the most beneficial to
society and to human beings possible.
No,
let's make sure we make a fuck load of
money,
the most money we could possibly make
because getting something passed by the
FDA is a huge process that cost millions
and millions of dollars.
So by the time you actually do get a
product to market you,
you,
you have to protect that product.
You have to protect that,
that money.
It's all about money,
money and profit.
The best thing to do is just
be proactive enough about your health so
that you can do whatever is under your
control to prevent you from getting any
kind of acute disease.
Not to say that it doesn't happen
because of course it does,
but,
um,
you know,
I think there's lots of things that,
that could be more deeply explored that
then,
you know,
our culture really is sort of per
permittable too in kind of our,
you know,
what we accept as mainstream or not.
Like I,
I started recently a going to
acupuncture,
which I'd never done before.
It was before.
Yeah,
I've done it.
No,
I didn't,
I didn't think it was bullshit.
I mean,
you know,
I'm a pretty rational guy,
so the idea of sticking,
you know,
sort of like the idea of Meridians and
sticking needles into my forehead and I
was like,
I didn't really know I wasn't an
immediate,
you know,
somebody who's going to immediately jump
on that bandwagon,
but I know a lot of people who have
benefited from it and I was having some
things that I want to address,
like particularly sleep.
Like I've been challenged by sleep
lately and so I went to see my friend
who's a Chinese medicine doctor and he
started doing it on me and it was hell.
It was really helpful.
And it's interesting,
the idea of balancing energy systems and
you know,
kind of how it works.
I mean so ornate and,
and this,
you know,
my friend who's studying Chinese
medicine and he's still kind of in his
residency,
so he's working underneath like a,
this Chinese dude who's been practicing
this forever and they come in and the
guy literally the,
this,
this Chinese medicine doctor.
The only thing he wants to do is take my
pulse on both wrists and he,
he takes it with his thumb and a couple
different places and apparently his
touch is so finely attuned that he,
he can tell all kinds of things about
like where you're at based upon the
pressure of your pulse and you know,
the frequency and the tempo and all
these sorts of things.
So he wants to do that and then he wants
to look at,
uh,
your tongue and he could tell by looking
at your tongue,
like all sorts of crazy shit about where
you're at.
Disney for.
Interesting people love it.
Or do you believe in possible placebo
effect?
I think the placebo effect is powerful.
You know,
I'm,
I'm into trying anything,
you know,
why not right?
Like,
you know,
contempt prior to investigation.
That's a good way to get.
Get hoodwinked.
Yeah.
Something's got to happen.
Well,
I mean I think with,
but
is that better than saying I'm not going
to explore that because I think it's bs
without having any direct experience.
But I mean it's nice to have some sort
of proof something.
So how do you,
how do you,
how do you prove that,
you know,
you run some tests,
some tests on what have the guy proved
that they can actually do that?
Oh yeah.
Well,
I mean all I can tell you is that I was
having issues with sleep and relaxation
and this seemed to benefit and alleviate
my problem to some extent.
So we don't use that placebo is that the
herbs that he prescribed me,
is that the acupuncture?
It certainly could be those things
because you've got to think about like
sleep.
Oftentimes a psychological.
Oftentimes sleep is a matter of your
ability to relax and we've all been in
that situation before when you know you
have to be at work and five hours.
If I go to sleep right now,
I can get four hours sleep and you look
at that clock and for whatever reason
you,
you're stuck in that thing because you
know that you have to go to sleep right
this moment and the pressure of that
keeps you awake.
Even if you're tired.
If you take action to try to alleviate
that by acupuncture,
by water,
whatever it is,
they just,
the mere act of taking action will shift
your focus into a cure and you can
oftentimes start thinking that whatever
this placebo effect is real,
I'm not doubting that this guy has a
real app,
a possible a gift or whatever it is,
but wouldn't it be nice that we can
prove it?
Like,
wouldn't you want to prove that?
What do you want to just work with a
bunch of people and find out,
uh Oh look,
you know,
he's right.
This guy doesn't have a gallbladder
issue where he's right,
this guy does.
I just met a lot of fuckers doing your
zone of healers and all these becoming a
much more cynical about this kind of
stuff.
Even before that,
I.
There was a guy that was working with
all these mma guys that I know and it
was a zone healer and a,
he would press the back of your head and
tell you from the spots that he was
pressing what was wrong with you and
that.
But it was bullshit.
Like he,
he was like,
press harder here.
Does that hurt when I do that?
I'm like,
yeah,
because you press in harder stupid.
I'm dumb.
And like we had this conversation.
I'm like,
how is it?
How exactly is this working?
And he was like,
well,
your body's ability to heal itself is
dependent upon freeing your energy and
is how does that work?
How does that work?
And after badgering them with a bunch of
different questions,
the essentially admitted it was all
placebo effect.
I was like Jesus fucking Christ,
and he was charging like 160 bucks to
get adjusted and he would touch your
head.
Was this part of your show or to do
that?
I knew that was in the mixed martial
arts world who was dealing with all
these different fighters and Jujitsu
guys that had back injuries,
neck and it was a good chiropractor,
but this zone healing thing,
as he was getting into it,
the more I would like listen to it,
I was like,
okay,
what?
What do you.
You're telling me you could touch the
back of someone's head and press spots
and tell if they have a thyroid
condition the fuck out of here.
That's not true.
That's just not true,
and he kind of admitted it wasn't true.
He kind of admitted that ultimately what
he's doing is if you believe in what
he's doing,
it will fix what,
what you have this wrong with you
because ultimately there's another great
a radiolab podcast on a placebo effect
and there was one of them where they
were talking about this guy.
They hypnotized this kid with this
insane work problem,
skin warts.
So if you've ever seen people that have
worked all over their skin where they
become,
it becomes incurable by medication and
they convinced this kid that they had
hypnotized him and that it was going to
go away and it went away on his arm.
His arm was like completely free of
warts,
which has never happens.
When someone reaches such an acute level
of infection like this kid had and so
in.
In a sense,
it is real in a sense.
It's not who he is as long as you're
gullible,
as long as you're willing to
wholeheartedly jump in and believe it,
and I think that might be what's going
on with acupuncture.
That might be what's going on with a lot
of quote unquote Chinese medicine or
eastern medicine.
I think if you believe that they have
found you a cure,
your body starts producing whatever it
actually needs to fix whatever ailment
you have and thus it becomes actually
effective.
So the the method is not correct.
The method is a trick and that trick is
effective and that effective trick does
convince your brain to fix whatever the
problem is and it's really baffling and
it only works if you're not a discerning
critical person because if you're a
discerning person who's skeptical,
it's not going to work because then
you're going to hyper analyze whatever
it is or where the potential
possibilities of whatever it is and it
just won't.
It won't work,
which is weird.
There's no shortage of snake oil
salesman pitching all kinds of crazy
healing techniques,
you know,
no doubt.
But I think that in fairness,
you know,
acupuncture and traditions of Chinese
medicine east go back,
you know,
hundreds if not thousands of years,
which critique there.
Well,
so does slavery.
Yeah.
But people are not going to see
witchcraft doctors in west La.
Well they wouldn't believe.
So I think that it would,
I think that the,
the history and the,
the sort of,
um,
traditions behind it,
there is,
there is merit there is there though.
But one scientifically,
I don't know.
I mean I'm the wrong guy to ask about
that.
I think if you're the wrong guy to ask
about that,
you're probably the wrong guy to talk
about it.
Yeah,
probably.
But I think it's,
I mean,
listen,
you know,
I just know from my friend who's been
studying as me,
he's been in school for crazy long
periods of time.
But you say school,
do you do air quotes?
I think it's,
you know,
it's essentially like medical school was
nothing like medical school.
How about that are sticking needles in
people,
enlightened insights that in terms of
like studying physiology and studying
chemistry and organic chemistry and all
that kinds of.
It was like on Energy Meridians and
shock rose and all that jazz.
Right.
I mean,
isn't that like what it's based on?
There's some aspects of that.
Sure.
But there's a lot of herbal medicine.
I think too,
you know,
for whatever reason I thought you said
urban medicine now,
you know,
verbal or the study of herbs.
There's,
there's certainly some herbs that have
medicinal values.
One of my favorite herbs has massive
amounts of manipulate Oregano marijuana,
the.
But I just think that the sticking the
needles in you,
it's probably more that you're doing
something,
you're doing something to deal with it
and then doing something your body
reacts.
You know,
the weirdest thing that is kind of half
of what like sort of psychotherapy is to
the willingness to show up for it is to
walk through the door and to engage
somebody else is almost,
you know,
no doubt.
Half the battle.
Yeah,
no doubt.
There's definitely merit to that.
I mean,
and also like I said,
like the idea of any,
you know,
fill in the blank whenever type of
modality,
any type of therapy that's actually
effective,
even though it doesn't have any real
scientific basis to it,
the,
the effect is still real.
You still get a benefit from it.
Like this zone healing shit.
Like if you believe in it,
it will affect you,
which is kind of fucking crazy.
It's kind of crazy that in some ways
there's merit to it.
Well,
I mean let's just talk about meditation
and Mindfulness Practices,
right?
So if you want to apply your sort of
analytical perspective to that,
you can draw the same conclusions and
really I could tell you,
well,
I mean,
listen,
anybody who is a consistent who has a
consistent meditation practice will tell
you that it improves their life.
Right?
But do you know that a placebo,
like is there a provable,
you know,
thing that you sort of,
could you apply that same?
Um,
you know,
litmus test to that because this is
another sort of non western approach to,
you know,
being healthier.
But there's been a lot of studies done
on meditation.
I'm sure there's been a lot of studies
done on the effectiveness of mindfulness
and and the actual effect on the mind,
but it's in a theoretical thing,
right?
Yes,
but it's not lying to you.
It's not saying that this frog potion
that I give you is going to cure your
cancer and then your body cures the
cancer.
There's a certain aspect of meditation
that's undeniably beneficial,
but that,
that,
that aspect of it is really been
scientifically analyze.
They've done all these f MRI scans on
people that are Buddhist monks that have
spent years and years meditation.
They've done scans on people that were
in,
you know,
deep rem sleep and different stages of
the mind.
I mean,
there's.
There's a lot of scientific work that's
been done on what we call meditation,
achieving certain brainwaves,
achieving certain states.
Those aren't fake
and in a sense,
placebo effect isn't fake either,
right?
Because every drug that that exists
exists because there's a receptive for
it in the human mind.
The reason why those drugs are effective
is because the mind knows how to
actually produce that effect in some
sort of limited quantity on its own.
That's one of the reasons why placebo
effects work.
That's the reason why we have opiate
receptors,
cannabinoid receptors and all these
different things and processes that the
mind can engage in with or without
medication.
That's why those medications have an
effect on the body,
so in that sense,
placebos,
if you believe in them work,
there was really is something is there,
isn't it even more than that though,
like the placebo effect works.
Even when you know it's a placebo
sometimes,
right?
Sometimes we're not as much.
There was,
yeah.
Yeah,
there was and that's I think what we're
talking about.
Just doing something.
The act of doing something to deal with
it makes you focus on whatever the issue
is.
You know,
I mean how many issues that people have
health wise or just due to a complete
lack of awareness of their physical
body.
Just stumbling through life on this
drunk and momentum of coffee and donuts
and stress and cigarettes and traffic
and pollution and stress and cigarettes
and coffee,
coughing,
da bum ba bum,
bum,
bum.
And then just the,
just the mere act of taking the time to
reassess,
like what it means to be a person to,
to just stop and pause and give thought
to your,
your day to day existence might be
enough to reset a lot of the processes
that are in place.
Yeah,
I mean it's been huge in my life.
I mean,
it's so counterintuitive.
Like I would rather go out and do a four
hour run and sit down for 20 minutes in
the morning before I leave the house
and,
and engage in that practice.
And you know,
over the last six or eight months I've
really kind of dedicated myself to it in
a,
in a,
you know,
by prioritizing it.
And it's really,
it has been great.
What do you do?
How do you do it?
Um,
you know,
I've played around with so many
different techniques over the years and
you know,
you were talking about momentum earlier,
right?
Like I've never been able to like hit
momentum with it,
like I'll do it for a couple of days,
this version,
that version and I could never find a
way to really stick with it.
And I downloaded the headspace app which
has an iphone APP.
It's got guided meditation programs on
it and it started by this dude,
Andy Puddicombe who have had on my
podcast recently because I became so
fascinated with this guy and they're
very easy to follow a and I put it like
down in the dock,
you know,
like the bottom menu of my iphone.
So I see it in the morning and it's
super simple app and you just open it up
and it's got a whole series of programs
that you can do and I just the earbuds
in and he just kind of talks you through
it.
So he takes the thinking out of it and
it just makes it easy and I've been able
just,
just something about the ease of that.
I guess I've been able to kind of just
do it and create momentum around it and
like anything else,
once you have momentum and once you
start to see the benefits of it,
then you're more enthusiastic about
pursuing it further.
Um,
and it's been cool and this guy is,
he's really,
he's a cool dude.
He a British dude and he was in college,
dropped out of college.
You,
Andy Puddicombe,
Pud d I c o m,
b e a.
He has a great ted talk by the way,
but I grew up in London and dropped out
of college and what's in Nepal and
started studying buddhist meditation and
became a Buddhist monk and he lived
basically in relative seclusion for like
10 years as a Buddhist monk practicing
meditation and that he had this kind of
postmodern said a moment where he
realized like,
you know,
I need to go back to the west.
He had this calling to come back and be
a teacher and he started this company,
headspace,
that's become huge.
They've got like over a million
subscribers on this app.
He's developed this huge business around
it and he's very accessible.
He's friendly and engaging and very
modern and you know,
he sort of like,
where's live?
He lives here in Venice now.
He moved from London.
He lives here in Venice.
Schooldude.
Yeah,
there is his.
And then he um,
right before he wants,
once he decided he wasn't going to be a
monk anymore.
And before he kind of returned west,
he studied circus arts at the Moscow,
like college of circus and then went to
a concert.
Yeah,
like he became like a Spain,
like,
no,
like the,
like Cirque de Solei type stuff.
So he's got like this crazy skillset and
during his ted talk,
he's like juggling the whole time.
Really?
He's,
he's cool dude.
What,
what benefits have you found from this
meditation?
The biggest thing that I've found is
that,
um,
I'm able to navigate stressful
situations much more gracefully.
I'm far less reactive,
uh,
to people I'm able to kind of calmly
take information out,
engage it,
and then respond more mindfully and I'm
able to,
you know,
I've got a lot of stuff going on right
now is like,
you know,
it's just.
And to be able to kind of not get
anxious over that and just be able to
say,
okay,
you know,
focus on one thing at a time and not get
worked up about the smaller stuff.
Um,
and just ultimately a much more
productive and constructive in my
interactions with other people focused
when I'm working present with my wife
and my kids and calmer and it's impacted
my sleep as well.
It's been,
it's been cool.
I mean it's been,
you know,
I think the benefits,
I've exceeded what I expected.
I don't know how,
you know,
I didn't expect it to be any crazy
difference,
but it's been really great and it's sort
of like,
it's powerful too to be able to kind of
stand in your space and not get rattled
by things like that's a pretty potent
sort of
skill to develop.
Like just imagine yourself,
you know,
you're at work,
your boss is coming at you,
he accuses you of unfairly if something.
And you know,
what do you do?
Your like your buttons are pushed.
Like you're on autopilot,
you react in a certain way.
But to be able to like reprogram
yourself and go,
oh,
I have a choice here,
you know,
my brain is saying this,
but you know,
I don't have to engage in that pattern.
I can actually tell a different story
and react in a different way.
I think that's a,
that's a pretty powerful life skill
that's worth developing.
Yeah,
no doubt.
No doubt.
That's very cool.
I'm gonna.
Look into that and I'm definitely going
to download that APP and check out him.
That's,
that's fascinating stuff.
It's good stuff.
Do you ever fuck around with the sensory
deprivation tank?
I've been wanting to do that for so
long.
I want to go to the float lab and
Venice.
I've got a friend who's got a tank.
I know you're big into that.
I know that.
I would really dig it.
You have a tank?
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
So you know,
what are the.
You probably talked about this a ton on
your show already,
but like what if you could like
encapsulate the benefits of that
removes the mind from the body,
the,
the influence of the body and all the
stimuli of the world arose.
It evaporates.
Rather it just it.
It's the mine untethered from the body
in a very weird way and the way I always
describe it as if we were having this
conversation,
but right next door,
so you have people screaming at the top
of their lungs will be very distracting.
We would want to go,
let's go talk over here and that.
That screaming is information.
It's stimuli stimulus you.
You're constantly getting it right now
where we're sitting in,
even though these are very comfortable
or Ergonomic chairs from the Ergo depot,
cut Pisco chairs.
Very good for your posture.
I used to fucking these.
I used my package to kill me at the end
of every show,
but because of these chairs,
it's really fantastic,
but it's still.
You're still in a chair.
You're ass is pushing against it.
You feel the weight of your body.
You're moving around.
There's.
There's a desk in front of you.
We have visual cues.
We're hearing things.
We have earphones on.
There's all stuff that's going on
constantly that we look at it as the
world,
but it really what it is is data.
It's data coming into your brain that
your brain has to process and that data
life itself is a distraction in that
tank.
There is no data there.
You mean you have a very limited amount
of sensation of the fact that you were
in water that will eventually go away.
If you stay still long enough,
the water's the same temperatures,
your skin,
so you will get to a point where you
don't feel it.
There's a thousand pounds of salt in
that water,
so you'll.
You'll float effortlessly and you're in
total darkness and as long as there's no
bang around the room,
as long as you're in a good silent area,
you will experience quiet in a way that
is you never get.
You will experience physical quiet.
You will be no input and the absence of
that input,
your brain becomes supercharged.
It makes it so much easier for me to
understand influences,
objectives,
all the things that I had been pushing
to the back of my brain,
avoiding come to light instantaneously
highlighted,
uh,
all issues become highlighted.
Any,
any stumbling blocks,
any,
any things that you really need to
address all come to the forefront and
the way I describe it as the first 20
minutes or so seem like,
like a seminar on my life,
like my life is being explained to me.
Like,
here's,
if I went to a guru that could explain
to me in no uncertain terms,
like someone who really knows every
aspect of my life.
Like if you could plug a USB drive into
my head into some super computer that
can fix things,
they'd go,
oh,
well,
look at all these issues you have.
You have to get rid of this,
clean out,
this clutter,
stopped doing that because you don't
like it.
Don't do this.
Don't hang out with this person hanging
out with that person more concentrated,
more on this aspect of your life.
Just creatively.
It's an unbelievable tool.
Uh,
I go over a Jujitsu techniques in the
tank.
I go over transitions,
I go over,
stand up comedy in there.
I go over everything in there.
Yeah,
that's great.
I want to check it out.
I mean,
it sounds the way that you described
that is very similar to the experiences
that I have when I'm in long distance
running and training.
Sure.
It's,
that,
you know,
it's different because your heart's
beating and it's,
it's kind of an active meditation
version of that,
but,
you know,
it's so powerful,
and the more that I learn about this
world of mindfulness you,
it's just,
it's untapped reservoirs of potential
personal potential.
Exactly.
And um,
you know,
again,
it goes back to,
you know,
western culture priorities like this is
not,
you know,
this is,
the float lab like your tank.
That's not a mainstream idea.
You know what I mean?
It's becoming more so.
But yeah,
but I mean to look the typical American,
right.
You know what I mean?
It's kind of a foreign idea,
but this idea that you know,
your thinking mind is,
is,
is distinct from your higher
consciousness and to the extent that you
have control and you can harness your
thinking mind for your benefit and
you're able to,
you know,
silence the idol,
negative chatter,
you know,
most people like you said,
it's coffee,
donuts,
whatever.
Um,
there is a looping,
you know,
in my mind loops as much as the next
person and generally it's not very kind.
Things that are looping self defeatist
ideas,
negative thoughts.
Oh my God,
I'm going to do Joe Rogan's podcast.
What if the desk squad army gangs up on
me?
You know,
what's going to happen?
like whatever it is.
You know what I mean?
Like at meditation allows you to
understand that you don't have to engage
in that.
It gives you a toolbox to say,
let me tell a different story.
I don't have to entertain that story,
that story that I've been listening to
my entire life that's led me down a
certain path in my life and helped sort
of forge a certain
trajectory.
What if I tell a new story
and let's put that story together and
see where that leads like,
could there be anything more powerful
than that?
Very few things.
No.
Acting on those positive thoughts.
Write that.
That's just as powerful if not more.
That's it.
Yeah.
And and uninstalling those buttons,
that car that causes you to react and
create negative consequences for you.
That's a good way to end this podcast.
The rich roll.
That was three hours of awesome.
Was it?
Yeah.
Thanks.
Damn,
it's done.
Thank you man.
Your podcast available on itunes.
What is the name of the people get rich
roll podcast.
Perfect name.
Absolutely.
Can I pitch my book?
You know,
plant power way,
way out this week.
Oh,
is it out this week?
And lifestyle guy.
Modern.
Excellent.
Poppy's friendly lifestyle guide,
right man.
Thank you very much.
Awesome.
Thanks for having me,
dude.
Anytime.
Man.
We're local.
So,
uh,
let's do this more often than once every
two years or so.
When was the last time we went down?
Man,
I'd love to have you on my show too.
If you're,
I would love to.
Um,
I'm excited that you have a show to your
really interesting and fun guy.
Yeah,
man.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Rich Roll.
Ladies and gentlemen.
You can find him on twitter ritual on
twitter,
a ritual.com,
[inaudible] dot com.
And,
and check out his podcast.
Check out his book the plant power way
available right now.
You fucks.
Go get it.
Thank you man.
Yay.